Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim.
Und ich begrüße alle zur fünfundsechzigsten Ausgabe von UKW und zur
Folge von Corona Wickly, denn heute ist Freitag und da heißt es wieder äh heißt es wieder hinterher wischen, äh hinter dem ganzen Infektionsgeschehen in Deutschland und der Welt
und das mache ich natürlich zusammen mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Genau und ja, eine wilde Woche liegt hinter uns in jeder Beziehung. Du hast äh wenig Schlaf gefunden, wenn ich das richtig bin
bekommen habe im Kampf mit äh Servern, Tabellen, Datenbanken, äh Bucks und was sonst noch alles auf dem Weg war
Die Bundesrepublik Deutschland hatte mit dem Umstand zu kämpfen, dass äh die Impfung vorübergehend eingestellt wurden, zumindest für den Impfstoff Astra Cineca, einmal Hüh, einmal Hot
mittlerweile läuft's wieder große Aufregung aller Orten und generell macht sich so ein Gefühl breit
dass es irgendwie alles nicht so geil läuft, insbesondere, weil die Zahlen wieder nach oben gehen. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, man merkt
auch und ich merk's, ich hab's auch ehrlich gesagt so so gar an mir gemerkt
dass so sich so so eine allgemeine Dünnhäutigkeit langsam bahnen bricht. Also die Leute gehen echt auf dem Zahnfleisch. Es ist so die einen haben sie schon immer über alles aufgeregt, aber auch die, die so,
bisher immer so Zähne zusammengebissen haben und gesagt haben so, ja ist Scheiße, aber es gibt ja Perspektive und so. In dem Moment als
diese Ansage war mit Astra Sinika ist jetzt irgendwie ausgesetzt. Da da haben's auch dann einige so ein bisschen,
einfach verloren in dem Moment und mir ging's für so einen kurzen Moment auch so, obwohl ich mir dachte so.
Das ist doch nicht euer Ernst und auch wenn sich das Ganze so im Nachhinein und da werden wir jetzt auch nachher nochmal ausführlich drüber reden.
Auch wenn sie im Nachhinein dann wieder,
ergeben haben, wo man dann denkt so, ja okay, gut, müssen wir jetzt auch nochmal drüber diskutieren. Ist ja immer wieder was Neues, aber das ist trotzdem so ein Moment wie wenn man, wenn man in die Luftmatratze irgendwie das Ventil aufmacht und.
Das Gefühl hat, jetzt muss man wieder fünf Stunden pusten, bis bis man wieder auf dem selben Druck angekommen ist.
Ja, na, ich hatte meinen persönlichen.
Tiefpunkt glaube ich eher so vor einem paar Wochen äh als halt klar war, dass äh ja sich das Land entschieden hat in eine dritte Welle äh zu gehen. So.
Den August. Das war bei mir so der Punkt, wo ich mir dachte, ah kann man nicht vielleicht einmal alles richtig machen und,
irgendwie äh ein bisschen uns am Riemen reißen und irgendwie mal ja die Zahlen runterkriegen, aber nee, ist halt nicht. Äh da sind halt, ich meine, es ist halt, ja, dieses Beis.
Typische Beispiel, dass äh die Interessen von ganz vielen einzelnen, dafür sorgen, dass äh irgendwie alle am Arsch sind äh hinterher.
So die einen wollen ihre Kinder in die Schule schicken und in ihre Kitas bringen und ja treiben die Zahlen nach oben und am Ende sind wir die Schulen zu und die Kitas
zu und so. Die anderen wollen die Wirtschaft am Laufen halten. So, aber dann sind die Zahlen oben und die äh äh Wirtschaft kommt nicht in Gang.
So und so kannst du das halt einfach durchdeklinieren und das einfach die Lehre, dass eigentlich nur niedrige Instituzen äh allen zugute kommen.
Als ich schon wieder nicht so richtig rumgesprochen, ja.
Ermöglichen ja. So und dann hast du auch die einen.
Die einen äh meinen, na ja, jetzt kommt, wir müssen nichts tun, weil demnächst kommt der Sommer und dann äh verschwindet es alles von ganz alleine äh so, was ja, wie man sieht, natürlich nicht der Fall ist
Jetzt habe ich den Faden verloren, egal.
Ja man verliert da auch schnell den Faden. So, also jeder hat irgendwas einzuwenden und das es kommt immer wieder auf diesen Spruch zurück so in Gefahr und höchster Not ist der Mittelweg, der tot, äh bringt der Mittelweg den Tod, weil.
Ja, wir uns halt einfach auf nichts Konsequentes einigen können, so, ne? Man kann's, glaube ich, auch schon mal vorweg
schieben, wir haben's ja schon tausendmal gesagt, aber es wird angesichts der aktuellen Zahlen, Entwicklungen halt mal wieder ganz evident
sofort alles dicht machen, so hart wie es nur irgendwie machbar ist, so wirklich also jeder, der nicht irgendwie wirklich äh auf einer Seite ausführlich innerhalb von fünfzehn Minuten darlegen kann, warum es dieses Unternehmen und diese akt,
gerade braucht, zum Überleben des Planetens, wird
einfach zugemacht so und das machst du zwei Wochen und dann hast du irgendwie so einen chinesischen R von null Komma vier und dann ist das Ding nach zwei Wochen vorbei und alle finden's scheiße,
aber alle finden's auch total geil, dass es nach zwei Wochen vorbei ist und stattdessen, ja.
Ja, die zwei Wochen gelten aber nur, wenn man rechtzeitig reagiert,
wenn man halt das erstmal so, dann sind's halt vier bis sechs Wochen, äh die man dann im harten Lokdown verbringen muss, aber im Prinzip kann man jede Inzidenz eigentlich mit einem konsequenten Lokdown in vier Wochen äh einstellig kriegen.
Ja so es geht, das haben wir gesehen in anderen Ländern ähm so und wir haben auch.
Zwar nicht nicht beim ersten Lokdown, das nicht ganz geschafft, aber äh sechs Wochen haben wir halt äh geschafft beim ersten.
Um wieder öffnen zu können und wie gesagt, haben dann bei einer, ja, Institz von neuen äh erst gelockert und dann bei einer Institanz von drei.
Wir hatten eigentlich hatten wir Corona im Sommer fast besiegt. Äh hätten wir einfach nur noch ein bisschen länger durchgehalten im Sommer, ein bisschen mehr aufgepasst, dass halt die Infektion nicht in solchen Mengen wieder hier reingetragen wird. Ja
hätten hätten, ja.
Zum Fahrradkette. Genau, so ist es. Ähm.
Dann lass uns doch mal auf die Zahlen schauen erstmal so was das allgemeine Infektionsgeschehen betrifft und danach können wir auch schon mal so die ersten Erkenntnisse aus der neu strukturierten,
Tabelle herauslesen, aber jetzt sehen wir ja vor allem erstmal, ich glaube Herr Spahn hat in seiner.
Letzten, ich hab's leider nicht gesehen, ist jetzt nur hören sagen, aber er meinte sowas viel, ja, die Zahlen gehen ja beunruhigt nach oben, denn damit hätte ja keiner rechnen können.
Hört ihr nicht UKW oder was? Also das ist einfach unklar.
Nein, aber auch äh ich meine in welchem Paralleluniversum äh lebt der eigentlich ist, aber in welcher äh keine Ahnung Social Media Bubble oder ähm
bewegt er sich, also ja nicht mehr vor allen Dingen also dazu braucht man noch nicht mal jetzt uns, äh, sondern eigentlich alle Experten seit Wochen, ja?
Ähm ist klar, dass äh das kommt, ja. So, ähm also ja.
Okay, was haben wir denn jetzt.
Zahlzahlen. Ja. Ähm die Insedenz ist über hundert. So,
die deutschlandweite. Genau und zwar weil wir auch gebieten worden sind, dann doch äh auch vielleicht mal konkrete Zahlen äh zu nennen. Also.
Jahrhunderteins nach hunderteins Komma null.
Nach publizierten Fällen und tatsächlich aber weil das ja noch die Daten von gestern sind nach Meldedatum waren's halt äh noch fünfundneunzig Komma sechs, aber.
Ja, die Zeitungen melden äh über hundert und.
Auch die Zahl der Bundesländer, die jetzt über hundert liegt, steigt, ich bin jetzt froh, dass ich diese neue Farbe eingeführt habe ähm,
für den ja für den Condition Ultra äh und äh.
Ja, sind jetzt Thüringen so mit der höchsten Institz, die dürften bald die zweihundert überschreiten.
In den nächsten Tagen äh oder wahrscheinlich sogar morgen Sachsen mit hundertvierundvierzig. Berlin ist auch morgen über hundert ähm.
Mit neunundneunzig Komma drei hm.
Hessen hundertneun, Sachsen-Anhalt, hundertzwanzig, also ja, Bremen
lag auch lange Zeit so gut äh Brandenburg, Hamburg, Deutschland, also eigentlich Schleswig-Holstein und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
dümpeln noch so na ja was heißt dümpeln, Schleswig-Holstein,
Am besten mit siebenundfünfzig Komma drei noch und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern mit neunundsechzig eins. Aber ist,
ist ja ziemlich sicher, dass die meisten Bundesländer in den nächsten vier Wochen.
Die nicht nur die hundert überschreiten werden, sondern viele davon auch die zweihundert und ja.
Oder mehr. Also die Zahlen geht ja doch beträchtlich nach oben.
Und was halt auch noch äh nicht schön ist, ist, dass die Rewerte jetzt teilweise.
Für manche Bundesländer massiv angestiegen sind, also in Berlin haben wir eins Komma eins acht, hm.
Ach so, welchen Wert nimmst du jetzt gerade.
Ja, also drei einunddreißig Prozent ähm sozusagen Zuwachs.
Aber einen R sieben sieben Tage Airwert von eins Komma eins acht eins Komma eins neun deutschlandweit und Berlin ja eins Komma drei zwei, sorry, äh, hatte ich Berlin gesagt, ich.
Genau, womit das Deutschland, deswegen wunderte ich mich jetzt gerade
Ja, nee, also Berlin knallt voll, obwohl wir vor zwei Wochen uns noch gewundert haben, warum Berlin so deutlich unter eins liegt. Die haben also auch die komplette Kehrtwende äh hingelegt so und ähm ja, dementsprechend geht jetzt alles nach oben.
Ich habe äh heute auf Twitter wurde natürlich dann auch gleich wieder äh diskutiert, mal so ganz salopp draus gefolgert, dass wir jetzt im Prinzip vom Infektionsgeschehen wieder da sind, wo wir kurz vor dem Doktor Light fahren.
Weil sowohl Inzidenz als auch Anstieg äh vergleichbar ist. Kann man so sagen, ne?
Ja, ja, ich denke.
Also jetzt haben wir sozusagen so vier Monate Logdown gemacht und dann einen Monat das zerredet.
Um jetzt wieder genau da zu sein, wo wir am Anfang waren. Mit der einzigen, mit dem einzigen kleinen Trostpflaster, das durch die Impfung.
Nicht ganz so viele,
zu beklagen sind und die Totenteiler sich glaube ich auch immer noch nach unten entwickeln, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Aber das ist dann halt auch schon die ganze gute Nachricht, die es derzeit so zu verkünden gibt. Und das Ganze hat jetzt richtig
Wumps, ne? Also es ist halt die das alte Lied mit den exponentiellen Zahlen und äh gerade äh gut das kann sich jetzt natürlich in einzelnen Bundesländern binden einer Wochenfrist auch immer schnell ändern. Das haben wir ja gesehen. Trotzdem,
die Tendenz ist halt eher.
Noch höhere Zahlen und wir hatten ja schon vor, jetzt muss ich das mal gucken, vor zwei, drei Wochen als diese äh ganzen ähm.
Äh neuen Lockerungsmaßnahmensankündigungen gemacht wurden, ne? So nach dem Motto, jetzt machen wir erstmal die Schulen auf und dann so ab dem siebten März, dann geht's dann irgendwie schrittweise los. Da war ja dann so die Einschränkung, na ja gut, aber so.
Nur wenn unter fünfzig oder wenn unter hundert und ansonsten machen wir gleich wieder zu.
Und was ich letzte Woche schon hätte erwähnen können, in dem Zusammenhang, das hast du ja wahrscheinlich auch gesehen, das ging ja auch auf Twitter irgendwie sofort rum, diese Meldung von diesem Elbe-Elster-Kreis.
Der dann irgendwie eine Institz über hundert schon hatte, also dem Geschehen so ein bisschen voraus war, nur mal so zum Vergleich, wenn man jetzt mal kurz schauen, wo die jetzt gerade äh sind. Wie sich das seitdem entwickelt hat.
Aber da waren sie sozusagen gerade so bei hundertdreißig oder so, glaube ich, zu dem Zeitpunkt, als die Diskussion aufkam. Jetzt sind sie bei zweihundert.
Moment nicht falsch gucken, zweihundertdreiundzwanzig und.
Man ging halt so über die hundert rüber und es war ja so der Konsens. Okay, ab hundert machen wir dann aber wieder was. Ja, Kommentar von dem Landrat.
Ja, wir werden eigentlich gefordert zu handeln, haben uns aktuell aber anders entschieden. Und besser kann man, glaube ich, irgendwie die Reaktion auf Deutschland und in dieser Krise überhaupt nicht zusammenfassen, ja?
Ja, aber wir werden eigentlich gefordert zu handeln, aber haben uns aktuell anders entschieden. Leute.
So können wir das auch einfach sein lassen. Dann sagen wir einfach die Party ab. Ja, dann einigen wir uns gleich auf äh zwanzig zweiundzwanzig.
Wenn das Jahr äh jetzt komplett verloren sein soll, mit solchen Flitzpiepen ist einfach kein Staat zu machen.
Nein, das ist vor allen Dingen dann wieder auch ähm ja kommt als,
wieder das Argument näher die Intensivstationen sind ja noch nicht voll. Wir haben ja es gibt noch Platz auf den Intensivstationen ja
das ist sozusagen darauf, äh wo sie sich jetzt gerade zurückziehen, nur wie wir halt auch wissen, ist.
Kommt halt dann verzögert und das kommt halt trotzdem und ähm nur weil wir jetzt die achtzig plus
zur Hälfte durchgeimpft haben oder vielleicht ja jetzt fast zwei Drittel wahrscheinlich weiß man halt leider auch nicht ähm wie viel,
Prozent bei uns ähm altersmäßig eigentlich jetzt 'ne Impfung erhalten haben oder zumindest hab ich keine Zahlen gesehen an sich sollte das RKI das auch wissen,
Ja äh so dass wir eigentlich gar nicht abschätzen können, aber beziehungsweise.
Bei der letzten Abschätzung vor zwei Wochen war klar, dass in Berlin höchstens die Hälfte der achtzig Plus geimpft waren, jetzt werden's wahrscheinlich mehr sein. Ein Fortschritt gemacht haben, aber
auch die Altersgruppen dann bis sechzig.
Ähm sind halt auch noch hochgefährdet und da geht es erst im April los,
Also und ja das geht nicht, das kann man nicht so machen. Ähm.
Zumal ja.
Auch wenn man sich die normalen Sterbetafeln anguckt selbst hat bei den über Achtzigjährigen sind in der letzten Welle, haben gesagt, hundertfünfzigtausend Lebensjahre verloren gegangen und bei.
Den jetzt wenn's jetzt in die jüngeren,
reingeht, werden wir im Endeffekt werden zwar weniger Menschen sterben, aber es wird wahrscheinlich dieselbe Größenordnung an Lebensjahren verloren.
Gehen. So und ähm ja.
Gut.
Wir sind unzufrieden mit der Gesamtsituation. Wir können das auf jeden Fall schon mal zusammenfassen.
Ergänzend wollte ich noch zu den Zahlen der Toten sagen, es gibt also in Brandenburg gehen sie wieder leicht hoch schon und in Thüringen gehen sie zumindest nicht runter.
Mehr. So, das äh fehlt eigentlich noch zu erwähnen ähm und.
Ja um das auch nochmal möchte an der Stelle nochmal mit den Testzahlen gleich zu untermauern, was den.
Dass jetzt bedeutet Tests sind mehr geworden so. Wir haben jetzt
und acht Prozent mehr Tests in der Woche bis zum vierzehnten gehabt. Die Zahlen kommen leider auch immer ein bisschen verspätet. Also wir liegen jetzt bei knapp eins Komma zwei fünf Millionen Tests in der Größenordnung.
Haben wir ja im September im Prinzip getestet, wir sind dann noch bis Ende Oktober lagen wir auch so in KW zweiundvierzig sagen wir auch ungefähr in der Größenordnung, ja.
Und hatten damals eine positive Quote von drei Komma fünf acht Prozent so zum Vergleich.
Ja und das war zu Beginn der Pandemie und das ging dann recht schnell hoch, also dein Vergleich.
Ist, was so die Testzahlen angeht und auch die positiven Quote mit Anfang der letzten Welle passt ganz gut, also.
Vor der letzten Welle, sondern.
Vor der zweiten Wille.
Ja, also wie auch immer man die durchnummeriert, ob's jetzt in der dritten oder vierten Welle sind, aber vor der.
Jetzt.
Voller Winterwelle, genau.
Genau, Ende Oktober halt, ne? Also Ende Oktober,
so wie jetzt und und da war dann halt diese Debatte auch so, oh Gott, was tun wir denn jetzt, müssen wir denn jetzt wieder was tun? Und dann haben wir endlich mal was getan, obwohl's damals schon eigentlich zu spät war. So, ne? Und dann haben wir noch zu wenig getan und
das ist exakt genau das, was uns jetzt auch droht, weil wir werden jetzt deshalb allein schon zu wenig tun, weil die Leute einfach den Arsch nicht in der Hose haben, irgendwas zu entscheiden
besondere, weil sie alle jetzt schon so zu Scheiße genervt haben, dass sie sich das gar nicht mehr trauen, das auch nur auszusprechen, dass das jetzt erforderlich wäre. Also werden sie es jetzt noch, zwei, drei Wochen verzögern.
Um dann einzusehen, dass es doch nicht durchzuhalten ist.
Ja? Weil wieder alles irgendwie Krankenhäuser voll und Pipapo und noch mehr schlechte Nachrichten.
Dann wird dann doch noch ein Lokdown gemacht, der muss dann nochmal ein paar Wochen länger sein, als er jetzt schon viel zu lange wäre, wenn er überhaupt einer wäre und dann habe ich sogar nochmal den Zweifel, ob der überhaupt.
Ausreichend noch ausgestalltet wird. Weil ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, es haben sich jetzt alle so drauf eingeschossen so. Ne, die sitzen da so ein bisschen mit ihren Joysticks,
und und und spielen so irgendwie was weiß ich so wie man früher vorm Homecomputer so Summer Games gespielt hat und ruppelt solange an ihrem Joystick rum und so weiter und hoffen, dass einfach mit den Impfungen jetzt irgendwie was passiert. Ne, so,
Impft doch impft doch schneller. Ja aber wir haben noch gar nichts zum Impfen. Ja, aber impft trotzdem schneller. Funktioniert nicht.
Muss aber jetzt unbedingt noch die positiven Quote nennen, das habe ich glaube ich noch nicht getan. Es ist nämlich sechs Komma sieben sieben.
Prozent äh jetzt, weil ein Hörer sich beklagt hatte, dass äh er beim Autofahren dann äh hört halt und dann unbedingt wissen wollte, wo sie denn jetzt ist und dann haben wir sie nicht genannt und der Made fast ins Lenkrad gebissen.
Täuschung und deswegen, also.
Nochmal, ja, hier nochmal sechs, also von sechs Komma zwei in der Vorwoche auf sechs Komma sieben sieben Prozent, äh, jetzt die positiven Quote und.
Fünfzehn Prozent mehr äh positive Tests.
Und äh bei acht Prozent mehr durchgeführten Tests.
Und auch das entspricht in etwa der positiven Quote kurz vor dem Logdownlight, ne? Da waren wir bei sieben Komma zehn. Also wir haben absolut vergleichbare Zustände und ja dementsprechend sind wir jetzt wieder da, wo wir vor vier Monaten waren.
Was für eine Zeitverschwendung, wobei gut, man kann.
Vielleicht nicht ganz äh das Zeitverschwendung nennen, weil ähm da würde ich dann nehme ich ganz gerne.
Jetzt mal eine schöne Auswertung.
Erwähnen, die ich gemacht hatte und zwar hm.
Gibt es ja in äh meiner Tabelle auch diese einfache vier Wochen,
Prognose sag ich mein Prognose ist schon fast hochgegriffen ist eigentlich nur 'ne Hochrechnung des aktuellen Zustands,
wo landen wir, wenn der RW so bleibt, wie er am heutigen Tag ist, was natürlich nie der Fall ist. Natürlich landen wir nicht da, aber,
wir können da landen oder wir landen da, wenn nichts passiert, wenn wir nicht reagieren, dann landen wir da. So. Ähm und.
Das habe ich halt dann mal aufgetragen ähm mit dem dann realen Infektionsgeschehen und,
ist schon interessant, weil die Kurve, die nämlich dabei rauskommt, dann also diese Kurve der Prognosen sieht eigentlich eher fast so aus wie die Kurve, die Tschechien gefahren hat
von der Höhe her, das heißt man kann schon sagen, dass äh.
Ohne den Lokdown Light wir äh zeitweise.
Halt Zahlen hatten, die uns in vier Wochen auf eine Institz von über tausend gebracht hätten. Also die Institenz von tausend war quasi in greifbarer Nähe.
Wenn man so will.
Das wäre Preis gewesen.
Ja, aber äh wie man dann äh sieht, ist es halt glücklicherweise vermieden worden. Also insofern
muss man konstatieren, hat halt der Logdown Light zumindest da eine ganze Menge abgekappt äh von der ersten Welle und
Hm, ja und er zeigt aber auch, dass so zu verschiedenen Stellen,
die Prognosen deutlich günstiger waren, also dass wenn wir einfach nur ein bisschen durchgehalten hätten. Wir dann
deutlich niedriger,
gekommen wären, was sich dann aber auch nicht realisiert hat, weil ja wir uns dann angefangen haben zu entspannen und ähm halt die Zahlen dann langsamer wieder runtergegangen sind,
Ja und aktuell ist es so, dass äh ja, die Vorhersage.
Die vier Wochen Vorhersage.
Oder Projektion oder wie auch immer. Ähm bei dreihundert steht. Prinzip ist diese Zahl auch so ein, so ein empfindlicher, großer, langer Zeiger, der.
Ähm ja übertrieben reagiert, aber der so ein bisschen anzeigt, was möglich ist. Und äh ja, wenn wir einfach nur so jetzt nichts tun, dann schaffen wir die dreihundert in vier Wochen.
So sieht's halt gerade aus, aber es wird natürlich nicht eintreten, hoffe ich ähm.
Oder ich erwarte es eigentlich nicht, ich erwarte, dass ja.
Was passieren wird, dass die Leute weiter aufpassen werden, aber wer weiß, wie in Tschechien haben die Leute das dann einfach ignoriert, die hatten dann irgendwann einfach keinen Bock mehr und ja.
Haben dann doch die tausend gemacht.
Also was ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen schwieriger macht, ist, dass wir eben jetzt ähm.
Es ist es ist Mitte März so. Als nächstes kommt irgendwie Ostern. Da wollen dann alle wieder irgendwas machen, dann dürfen sie es nicht machen, dann machen sie es trotzdem
Ja, es wird dann wärmer
Jetzt ist gerade das Wetter so ein bisschen so, hm, aber lass mal nur irgendwie eine einmal Sonnenschein äh auf Deutschland fallen. Da äh ziehen sich alle nackig aus und rennen an den Strand. Das ist
verständlich, ja? Äh und natürlich ist es viel, viel, viel schwieriger dieses, ich hocke zu Hause rum und mache nix durchzuziehen, wenn draußen auch noch geiles Wetter ist.
Ich glaube, wir hatten das neulich äh äh schon in der Sendung, dass dass also schon das dieses kurze Aufflammen eines Frühlingwetters
sofort in den Mobility Daten.
Zu sehen war, ne? Also alle gleich zack ins Auto, äh ab ins Grüne oder was weiß ich, Leute besuchen zusammenhängen. Gibt's zwar auch immer wieder einzige Einzelne, die nehmen's halt total ernst und wenn sie sich da irgendwie treffen, machen sie irgendwie Schnelltest und so weiter, aber ich glaube.
Braucht man jetzt gar nicht so viel Hoffnung reinzustecken, dass durch äh singuläres ähm richtiges Handeln im privaten Bereich so generell irgendetwas besser wird, sondern wir werden einfach eine die also die Prognosen sind.
Schlecht, weil.
Wenig Indikatoren, dafür gibt es wir äh Bock haben uns noch mehr zusammenzureißen. Wir haben's bisher nicht getan. Alle sind müde.
Alle wollen, dass es jetzt irgendwie anders wird, alle haben auch erwartet, dass jetzt dieser lange Winterlokdown irgendwie auch was was bringt so und dann ging's halt los vor.
Was haben wir da jetzt vor vier, fünf Wochen? Hatten wir das glaube ich hier so Sachsen mit ja jetzt machen wir mal Schulen auf. So das.
Das war eigentlich der Anfang. Und das ist ja hier auch so ein bisschen unsere vertretene These, äh die sich immer ein bisschen schwer belegen lässt. Vielleicht müssen wir da auch nochmal eine passende Grafik zu raushauen.
Indem wir ein paar mehr Medienmeldungen mal sammeln und in in Kontext bringen, ne? Aber du hast das ja schon mal schön rausgearbeitet. Es ist die.
Es ist der öffentliche Diskurs. Es ist die Änderung der Debatte in der Öffentlichkeit, die einen wesentlichen Einfluss auf die Trendwechsel hat.
Und das ist jetzt quasi wieder einmal sichtbar
geworden, weil kaum war diese Debatte oben, kaum ging's los, ja als mit Firma Schulen aufmachen, jetzt müssen wir das aufmachen. Dann wollten alle anderen auch aufmachen und dann wollten die Friseure aufmachen und dann wollten wir diese und jene und Restaurants und alle wollen aufmachen, aufmachen, aufmachen
weil sie halt alle ankamen mitten, aber wenn die aufmachen, dann müssen wir ja auch aufmachen. So und schon gingen die Zahlen erstmal nicht mehr weiter runter.
Und vor allem ist es so, so, ich sage mal, Politik oder wer auch immer.
Der da prominent medial äh gehört wird, sagt oh wir müssen mal äh jetzt darüber reden, äh dass wir mal langsam,
Schulen aufmachen, ähm so dann hören halt ganz viele Leute oh.
Ist ja nicht mehr so schlimm mit der Pandimie. Äh interessiert das Thema Schulen vielleicht gar nicht, sondern was halt die meisten einfach hören
ist das Signal von offizieller Stelle, da entspannt sich was, weil und da können sich dann wiederum auch andere,
hinstellen und sagen, nein, nein
passt auf, äh so es ist immer noch gefährlich. Ihr müsst euch irgendwie weiter schützen. Aber diese Nachricht kommt natürlich nicht an, wenn in,
gleichem Atemzug über Lockerungen gesprochen wird, ja,
weil wir hatten halt jetzt auch diese ganze Schulöffnungs- und Lockerungsdebatte, hatten wir jetzt auch auf Klubhaus und immer wieder in, in, in anderen Zusammenhängen, da kam mir verdammt, warum reden wir gerade überhaupt.
Über das Thema das ist 'ne absolute Unzeit,
ja? Äh so im Moment müsste unser Fokus sein, wie wir verhindern
dass uns das Ganze wieder komplett um die Ohren fliegt, ja? Wir müssen über äh Maßnahmen reden und nicht irgendwie Lockerungen äh debattieren. Es ist schon mal dann,
komplett der falsche Ansatz, der nirgendwo hinführt gerade. Ja, ich,
verstehe natürlich auch die praktische Seite, dass es natürlich Dinge nur funktionieren, wenn,
Leute das auch machen und umsetzen aber dann muss die Debatte eigentlich gehen um welche Maßnahmen sind geeignet,
Zahlen zu senken und nicht darauf angewiesen, äh dass die Leute von sich aus äh.
Auch das tun, also Maßnahmen ergreifen und
am Ende immer wieder der Lokdown leider die einzige Maßnahme, so die dann auch kontrollierbar ist und am besten hier auch Ausgangssperren, die sind halt am einfachsten kontrollierbar, wenn man das.
Gerne äh möchte. So alles macht zu, hat keiner einen Grund irgendwo hinzugehen und äh wer auf der Straße ist, draußen so.
Ähm der.
Wird eingefangen.
Brauche halt, genau, der braucht halt äh einen guten Grund und meine andere Länder machen das seit langem. Äh so, da,
darfst du dich halt auch darfst seit einer Stunde am Tag raus
so und dich nicht weiter als den Kilometer von äh deinem Haus entfernen und äh ja, wenn du zu anderer Zeit auf der Straße angetroffen wirst, wird's halt teuer. So.
Meine nicht, dass ich da jetzt irgendwie Bock drauf hätte oder das herbeireden will
aber äh ja wie soll's denn anders gehen, ja? Äh ich meine, es ist und das haben wir uns komplett selbst eingebrockt äh so die ganze Sache. Es war alles
wirklich unnötig, somit einfach ein paar Wochen Disziplin im.
Oktober und dann vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen ein, zwei Wochen im November und Dezember und.
Ja, wir äh kennen das alles viel entspannter sehen können, aber nie.
Dazu passen und dazu dass ich mich dann auch auf Twitter äh geäußert, weil ich immer wieder ins Maul nicht halten konnte. Ich habe hatte mich äh wie schon voll angedeutet, eine etwas dünnere Haut und musste mich dann irgendwie auch mal ein bisschen äh äußern. Da gab's dann im Tagesspiegel so einen Kommentar,
also ein Meinungsbeitrag, kein Nachrichtenbeitrag von so einer Dame, die
überschrieb ihren Artikel schon mit der Insidenzwert fetisch verhöhnt die Menschen.
Da war ich ja dann doch äh äh schnell äh getriggert. Ja, äh Untertitel äh das Land nähert sich nicht sehr überraschend dem Institanzwert einhundert sollen Schule, die gerade erst geöffnet wurden mit Schließung dafür zahlen.
Ja, wo ich sagen muss, also Zahlen.
Tun ja hier nicht die Schulen, ja? Und es ist.
Ja, der ja.
Man kann über den Institzwert natürlich kann man ganz vieles kritisieren und ist ja gerade auch wieder in der Debatte natürlich deswegen, weil äh so
ganz viele Politiker keinen Bock haben zu tun, was sie angekündigt haben zu tun, wenn die Institzwerte steigen und sich jetzt und jetzt den Institzwert in Frage
stellen, aber den Institzwert kann man einfach mal sagen, hinten anstellen, das Einzige, was interessiert ist,
steigt oder sinkt er und wenn der steigt, so dann ähm ja,
dann muss halt was passieren, weil der geht halt von alleine nicht nicht zurück. So einfach äh ist das und das ist egal, ob der Instituzwert jetzt bei fünfzehn, fünfzig oder fünfhundert liegt, wenn der
halt äh steigt, dann ist was nicht in Ordnung äh so und dann kann man nicht
kann man weder zur Tagesordnung übergehen oder einfach die Sachen so lassen wie sie sind und auf gar keinen Fall irgendwie weiter über Öffnungen
So eigentlich ist das, das Ding geht's rauf oder runter. So, das ist das Entscheidende und ja.
Da werden wir schon jetzt wieder bei dem bei dem Grafen es geht rauf und in allen Altersgruppen geht's gerade rauf.
Genau. Also ich fand diesen Artikel insofern ein bisschen schräg, ne. Also.
Überschließung nachzudenken, werden die Impfzentren an Wochenenden geschlossen sind, verhöhnt die Menschen, die tagtäglich mit diesen Folgen umgehen müssen, ja? Also Impfzentren.
Schließen am Wochenende, weil weil kein Impfstoff da ist und gerade weil wir nicht genug impfen können, deswegen schließen.
Die Schulen. Das ist so das Ding, ne? Und äh hat auch noch ein paar gute Punkte, ne, wie zum Beispiel so
Andere wollen jetzt irgendwie nach Mallorca äh reisen und so weiter
Also es ist halt immer dieser Vergleich, die anderen dürften aber das und warum müssen wir denn das äh tun
Ja gut, ich äh rege mich jetzt gar nicht weiter auf. Das bringt ja auch irgendwie gar nichts. Wir haben ja unseren Punkt jetzt hier eigentlich auch äh weitgehend rüber äh gebracht. Aber es ist einfach ein bisschen.
Schlimm, dass diese ganze Debatte sich da einfach nicht normalisiert,
Sag doch nochmal ein bisschen was äh zu deinen Zahlen. Also wir hatten ja jetzt ähm letzte Woche schon angedeutet, Risikotabelle äh ist komplett überarbeitet worden und du bist ja auch immer noch fleißig dabei, diese ganze ähm Auswertung noch weiter zu Granulaisieren, also nicht nur wie jetzt eben schon
die Unterscheidung zwischen Ländern und den einzelnen Landkreisen, sondern eben auch noch innerhalb dieser Landkreise komplett die komplette Zeit.
Historie abbildend und dann aber auch noch alle Zahlen relativ zu eine von fünf oder sechs Altersgruppen.
Ne? Äh und auch noch die Unterscheidung zwischen Männern und Frauen. Das ist ja sozusagen jetzt das äh Projekt, das ist noch nicht ganz
am Ende angekommen, da wollen wir jetzt mal nicht so viel Technik ähm zu erzählen, weil es langweilt nur die Kurzfassung ist, das dauert alles sehr lange
Und man muss da sehr viel Gerät und Software an Start bringen äh glaubt man gar nicht für die Parzahlen, aber ist so. Äh trotzdem hast du ja jetzt auch schon mal reingeschaut, ähm was sich denn,
Stichtprobenartig herauslesen lässt aus der neu gewonnenen Einsicht bezüglich der Altersverteilung und der Geschlechterverteilung.
Ja genau, das habe ich nämlich jetzt erstmals, ich hab halt für, sagen wir's bisher nur für Deutschland.
Gesamt ähm äh alles mal rausgerechnet und,
Bisher hat mir das Thema Geschlechter, also Unterschiede von Kovit, als bei Männern und Frauen hatten wir halt nicht so sehr beleuchtet, weil ich
einfach ja bisher äh die Zahlen oder Grafen da auch nicht hatte und.
Ja das ist halt doch interessant, weil hm jetzt,
in der zweiten Welle halt Frauen doch deutlich stärker betroffen waren bei den Institzen,
und.
Das sogar, ich meine, ich rechne die Inzidenzen auch jeweils pro Altersgruppe, also was klar ist, ist das natürlich mehr ältere Frauen als Männer gibt,
und äh äh aber das ist sagen jeweils die Institute wirklich gerechnet auf die Zahl der älteren Männer und Frauen, die es gibt und trotzdem zeigt sich da, dass halt während bei den Männern,
so die
sieben Tage Instit in der Spitze bei dreihundertfünfundzwanzig lag, ist sie bei den Frauen so auf ja knapp vierhundertdreißig äh angestiegen. Also sie sind.
Halt 'ne deutlich höhere Kurve hingelegt bei den achtzig Plus, jetzt
und auch noch eine interessante Anomalie ist, dass die sechzig bis neunundsiebzigjährigen
gibt es,
kaum Unterschiede. Da sind sogar die Männer ganz leicht stärker betroffen ähm so, aber komischerweise in der Alters.
Gruppe fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzig so bei den Frauen, die sind extrem stark.
Betroffen, also äh bei von den was die Institenzen angeht, die hatten,
teilweise Institzen eben auch bis zweihundertfünfundsiebzig in der in der Spitze und.
Ähm ja, das ist, das ist äh ungewöhnlich, also sagen die,
Die Gruppe der Frauen zwischen fünfunddreißig und neunundfünfzig
hat sich besonders häufig äh infiziert äh in der letzten Welle. Inzwischen sind die Zahlen dann wieder zusammengelaufen,
also mittlerweile äh gibt es da gerade keinen Unterschied mehr. Die laufen jetzt wieder synchron, aber irgendwas ist da in der Pandemie passiert, keine Ahnung. Äh warum habe ich jetzt keine Erklärung.
Du bist ja auch sicher, dass du da jetzt kein kein Wackler in deinen Daten hast?
Ziemlich, weil das ist alles automatisch generiert, auch die Labels sind.
Automatisch generiert und weil ich zuerst,
sagen beim Einfärben dann der Kurven war ich halt erstmal verblüfft, weil ich dachte gut, diese das ist die höhere Kurve, die wird einfach zu höheren Altersgruppe gehören, aber.
Nebenbei halt nicht so, deswegen bin ich mir da relativ sicher, äh dass das tatsächlich so ist. Das ist also hm, wer mal so ein interessanter Gegenstand, weiß ich nicht, ob man das aufklären kann.
Warum das so ist, warum eben Frauen in dem Alter sich so häufig angesteckt haben und ist halt, ja.
Also fast dreißig Prozent mehr, würde ich sagen in der in der Spitze.
Als als die Männer, das finde ich schon signifikant zumal äh das in den anderen Altersgruppen halt anders aussieht.
Wer würde ja als erste Erklärung sowas einfallen wie.
In dieser Zeit, in der so viel geschlossen hatte, ist vielleicht wahrscheinlich ja, dass Frauen mehr in so kritischen Jobs arbeiten, die so mehr Expros sind. Supermärkte und sowas.
Vielleicht ja es könnte sein ja äh Supermärkte.
Weiß nicht, ob das die Zahlen so erklären kann, aber das.
Mehr Einkaufstätigkeiten, aber vor allen Dingen auch Erzieherinnen, Lehrerinnen ähm ja also ich ich denke mal.
Dass das so einen Grund sein könnte, dass Frauen in dem Alter zu einem großen Teil halt in ja gefährdeten Jobs äh arbeiten.
Ja und bei den bei den ganz Jungen sieht man halt bis.
Bei den Fünfzehnjährigen eigentlich kaum Unterschiede, das das läuft fast gleich, da waren in der Pandemie.
Jungs auch minimal äh mehr betroffen, aber das sind einen einstelligen Prozentbereich aus dem Grafen, aber äh wo es.
Dann äh sich lustigerweise
auch wieder umdreht, ist dann wieder bei den ja fünfzehn bis vierunddreißigjährigen beziehungsweise das das könnte wahrscheinlich related sein, da liegen die Frauen dann schon bereits vorne.
Also ja, ich ich würde mal denken, dass das spricht sehr dafür, dass äh.
Frauen mehr in Berufen arbeiten, wo die Ansteckungsgefahr groß ist, ja.
Okay.
Ja, also da ist noch einiges an Gold zu heben, habe ich so den Eindruck in dem Datenmaterial, ähm kann man auch so einiges reinstochern
hoffen, dass das die Daten auch bald roh mal äh verfügbar sind, dass dann halt andere Leute, die da eintauchen wollen, auch selber mal auf die Recherche gehen können, haben sich auch schon einige Leute gemeldet, die
mithelfen wollen bei der Visualisierung. Wir versuchen das natürlich zu unterstützen, so gut es geht.
Ja, im Moment ist auch die sagen die Tabelle, die ich da gerechnet habe, äh die ist auch noch ein bisschen zu fett. Da sind halt viele überflüssige Zahlen rein.
Drin. Äh ich meine, die kann man sich, man kann sich viele von denen dann auch äh relativ schnell generieren, aber ich möchte die halt so zuschneiden, dass man nicht Tabelle mit
tausendvierhundert Spalten hört, weil auch Numbers hat ein Limit bei tausend Spalten. Was total bekloppt ist.
Weil du nämlich natürlich auch transponieren kannst, also äh Zeilen und Spalten vertauschen und dann passt's, was hal.
Total bekloppt ist. Ja, also warum diese künstliche Begrenzung da gemacht haben auf tausend Damen, den glauben die äh.
Dass irgendwie keiner auf der Welt äh.
Tabellenkalkulation mit mehr als tausend Spalten hat. Hier bin ich. Also.
Ja richtige Profi-Tools, alles schwierig.
Gut, dann müssen wir mal über das Astrazenika äh Desaster dieser Woche äh sprechen, auch weil wir uns da teilweise schon zu gemeldet hatten, ähm als die Datenlage noch ein bisschen unklar war. Das ist ja immer ein bisschen schwierig.
Ich denke es ist mal ganz wertvoll bisschen zusammenzufassen, was hier eigentlich passiert ist und und um ein bisschen zu versuchen zu verstehen, was eigentlich davon zu halten ist, ne.
Also ihr werdet es ja alle mitbekommen haben, die Impfungen mit dem Astrazinika Impfstoff wurde in Deutschland ausgesetzt. Anlass war, dass.
Bei der Beobachtung ähm der Personen, die geimpft wurden.
Die werden beobachtet, weil das ist ja auch Teil der Überprüfung, ne? Wir haben ja immer noch eine eine vorläufige Zulassung und das heißt, wenn der Impfstoff zum Einsatz kommt, erstmalig
dann folgt quasi automatisch der Phase drei, die er dann erstmal zur Zulassung geführt hat. Die Phase vier, sprich es wird dann,
Impfbetrieb auch immer wieder nacherfasst, okay, was sehen wir bei den Leuten, die geimpft wurden und was sehen wir im Vergleich dazu bei den Leuten, die nicht geimpft wurden, et cetera, PP und alle möglichen Nebenwirkungen, Erkrankungen et cetera sollen protokoliert werden, für die Leute, die geimpft wurden von euch
hatte ich hier schon mal erwähnt, es gibt da auch eine App vom vom PI hier, vom Paul Ehrlich Institut, die dafür zuständig sind, Safe Fu
da kann man das irgendwie auch alles reinhacken, aber viele Leute sind halt auch so einfach in Beobachtung.
Ja und dann wurde äh berichtet, dass es eben dreizehn Fälle gegeben habe einer speziellen Form einer Thrombose,
Also also einer Verstopfung der Blutbahn
in dem Fall aber im Hirn eine sogenannte Sinusvenenthrombose. Die ist an sich eine relativ seltene Geschichte.
Thrombosen wiederum sind nicht so äh selten, das ist glaube ich die dritthäufigste Sterbeursache auch in Deutschland, also es ist jetzt.
Kommen, Place, aber diese spezielle Sinusweden Thrombose, die kommt halt eher selten vor. Und das ist jetzt bei dreizehn Fällen in Deutschland aufgetreten bei Leuten, die eben vorher mit Astra Cenica,
geimpft worden sind von diesen zwölf, äh von diesen dreizehn waren zwölf Frauen da war ein Mann
alle im Altersbereich von zwanzig bis dreiundsechzig Jahre und drei davon sind an dieser Thrombose gestorben.
Ähm das hat dann ausgereicht die Alarmglocken schälen zu lassen, weil.
Die Zahl der Leute, bei denen das jetzt aufgetreten ist, bei den, die geimpft wurden in diesem Zeitraum, das überschreitet, was man halt normalerweise in der Bevölkerung sieht.
Also ne, das ist jetzt nicht so, dass das nicht passiert, sowas passiert. Und da gibt's halt bestimmte,
Erwartungshaltung dadran, wie oft das Binnen eines Jahres passiert, aber wenn das innerhalb so eines kurzen Zeitraums häufiger auftritt, dann ist das halt eine Anomalie und die muss eben und untersucht werden. Und deswegen wurden die Impfungen gestoppt.
Was ist jetzt mit dieser Sinus Thrombose, also soweit ich das mitbekommen habe und jetzt wird's natürlich wieder mal schwierig, weil medizinisches Feld, ne. Aber äh das Ganze tritt halt generell bei jüngeren Frauen häufiger auf.
Also sozusagen ein ein Phänomen, was was in dieser ähm Bevölkerungsgruppe häufiger auftritt.
Und in Vereinigten Königreich, wo ja auch sehr viel Astra Senika geimpft wird.
Gab's aber diese Häufung nicht.
Das war schon mal so ein bisschen so ein so ein Rätsel. Das muss man aber auch dazu sagen, dass halt.
In Deutschland, Astra Sinica, ja, wie wir uns alle erinnern, erstmal nicht an Ältere gegeben wurde.
Sondern eben generell nur an Leute unter fünfundsechzig
Und äh aufgrund der niedrigen Verfügbarkeit und der gezielten Verimpung, die wir derzeit halt noch haben, ist halt der Astrazinica-Impfstoff vor allem dafür verwendet worden, dann
ähm diese Gruppe zwei zu impfen und darin sind halt vor allem sehr viel Krankenhaus.
Personal, Pflegepersonal und äh noch ein paar andere in exponierten Bereichen und na ja.
Dann gibt es halt auch viele jüngere Frauen.
Das heißt, also was hier, was hier auf jeden Fall auffällig ist, ist quasi der Anteil von jüngeren Frauen automatisch höher ist.
Während sich halt in in Großbritannien äh die Impfung auf die komplette Bevölkerung erstreckt.
Beziehungsweise über die ihr auch erstmal mit den älteren Altersgruppen äh begonnen äh haben.
Und ähm sodass es dann Riesenunterschied gibt so in der Altersverteilung äh der.
Mit Astra Senika geimpften in Deutschland und äh eben in in England, so und,
jetzt die sich im Nachhinein rausstellt, was halt ja,
ziemlich ungünstige Entscheidung halt Astra Sinika anfangs nicht,
an die Älteren zu impfen, weil wir jetzt äh wie wir jetzt wissen, besteht halt wohl bei älteren äh Patienten äh dieses,
Risiko nicht, also diese Sinusen, Thrombose tritt wohl in höherem Alter dann einfach nicht mehr auf, weil.
Zumindest seltener.
Oder extrem ja extrem selten. Äh ja, sodass wir äh quasi genau das gemacht haben, so ähm was bei dem Impfstoff jetzt
ein bisschen einmal ungünstiger ist, wobei man auch dazu sagen muss, dass das nach wie vor trotz,
dieser Zahl der Fälle immer noch in einem Bereich liegt, der soweit ich das gehört habe ähm,
jetzt deutlich unter dem liegt, äh was jetzt bei der Anti-Baby-Pille äh zum Beispiel äh auftritt als.
Unerwünschte Nebenwirkung im Bereich Thrombosen, also die lösen die auch,
und ja und insofern.
Ist ich sag mal selbst dieser Zusammenhang und ähm ich gehe davon aus, dass da einen Zusammenhang äh durchaus besteht.
So ob der jetzt in dem Sinne ursächlich ist äh ähm so äh oder sagen wir so,
dadurch, dass es so selten auftritt, müssen natürlich bestimmte Faktoren hinzukommen, damit das passiert.
Und das Gute ist jetzt auch äh dass man zum einen jetzt wo man mehr weiß,
sagen, da auch entsprechend Vorsicht walten lassen kann und so wie ich gehört habe, ist, wenn man weiß, was es ist, ist es auch ganz gut behandelbar. So.
Äh wenn das auftritt, aber man kann da jetzt keine Medikamente wohl prophylaktisch
geben, das wird zu weit gehen, aber für den Fall, dass es äh jetzt sagen bei weiteren geimpften Auftritt zumindest ist das nicht hoffnungslos.
Also,
wofür ist jetzt auch noch so richtig keine Antwort gibt es, inwiefern ähm das jetzt wirklich ursächlich mit der Impfung zusammenhängt.
Denn was ja hier passiert ist so eine Blutgerinnung, ja und das Ganze ist.
Ich betone jetzt nochmal dünnes Terrain für mich, ja, weil Medizin ist überhaupt nicht mein Feld, aber das ist so ein bisschen der Eindruck, den ich bekommen habe, dass darüber diskutiert wird.
Dass das Ganze eben auch eine Reaktion ist auf die Reaktion des Immunsystems.
Also ich habe das zumindest bisher noch nicht gelesen irgendwo oder gehört, dass man jetzt annimmt, dass der Impfstoff als solcher.
Ja? Also sozusagen die Präsenz des
Dieses Vektorvirus, der da geimpft wird, der letzten Endes dafür sorgt, dass der, dass der Körper seine Immunreaktionen
startet. Das ist ja der Sinn dieser ganzen Geschichte. Das ist das ist jetzt
Der Impfstoff als Seucher ist, der das auslöst, sondern dass es sehr viel wahrscheinlicher ist, dass die von dem Impfstoff ausgelöste Immunreaktion.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit erhöht bei diesen Personen, dass es zu Thrombosen kommt.
Also es ist sozusagen auch entkoppelt von dem eigentlichen Astracinica im Stoff im kann durchaus sein und ich denke, da wird jetzt in der nächsten Zeit nochmal genauer hingeschaut werden, dass man eben auch vergleichbare Zahlen bei allen anderen Impfstoffen auch sieht.
Dass es eigentlich zu erwarten, vielleicht nicht in der selben Größenordnung, aber es gibt zumindest auch ähm soweit ich das verstehe und ich habe.
Auch das den ein oder anderen Artikel zu gelesen. Ähm dass es schon auch einen möglichen Zusammenhang gibt,
äh speziell halt mit den Spike-Proteinen, die dann ins Blut gelangen, äh die dann der der Körper produziert, weil äh wir ja.
Wissen, dass halt diese Spike Proteine und das gilt aber dann für alle Impfstoffe, egal
Genau, egal welchen du da du da nimmst, dass die halt
ja mit diesen berühmten ACI zwei Rezeptoren ihr äh sich dort andocken und selbst wenn das Virus tot ist und du hast halt da diese Proteine gibt es eine
Vermutung oder eine Möglichkeit, dass äh wenn die in höherer Konzentration vorhanden sind, dass die halt ähm
lang mit der Blutgewinnung äh.
Wechsel wirken. Da interagieren, dass die äh dass es sozusagen ein theoretischer möglicher Pfad ähm so und der andere.
Bisschen damit verwandt ist, es wissen halt auch, dass der, dass das äh Virus halt, das Interveron,
System äh durcheinander bringt und äh da äh ist halt auch die die Frage, hm ob.
Da an der Stelle ähm sagen auch ähm Proteinreste.
Sage ich mal oder Teile der Proteine möglicherweise äh.
Auch auch eine Wirkung äh haben auf das Immunsystem, die wir.
Noch nicht äh so ganz kennen und überblicken. Äh aber man muss auch immer dazu sagen, hm.
Bei den meisten.
Geimpften passiert einfach gar nichts. Irgendwie ein Drittel merkt man nicht mal irgendwas so richtig von der Impfung so den den.
Zahlen nach und ja,
müssen also eben immer noch ganz, ganz viele Faktoren, entweder genetische Dispositionen oder weitere gesundheitliche
Schäden oder ein bestimmter Status, der nicht so häufig auftritt dazu kommen, dass die Impfung dann
wo Parameter im Körper so verändert, dass das halt ja ähm zu mehr oder weniger.
Ungewünschten Wirkungen kommt.
Und vor allem eins muss man sich glaube ich auch nochmal klar machen. Diese Wirkung auf das Immunsystem.
Dieser Kampf, den quasi der Körper dann aufnimmt. Der hier zu Thrombosen.
Oder zumindest zu diesen Sinusfäden, Trantrombosen oder auch anderen Thrombosen führen kann in seltenen Fällen.
Dasselbe passiert, wenn man sich mit dem Virus infiziert.
Auch das ist sozusagen genau das, was Cowit neunzehn und das ist nicht nur das, aber das ist eine der Sachen, die Kowit neunzehn als Krankheit äh so,
unglaublich gefährlich und unangenehm macht, dass da eben auch Thrombosen auftreten. Und vermutlich aus dem selben Grund,
Weil nämlich da das Virus ein äh tritt, weil das Immunsystem hochfährt und dass in diesem Prozess eben äh diese Interaktion, mit diesen Blutplättchen, äh diesen Thromozyten,
aktiviert wird, ja? Die irgendwie versuchen hier irgendwas zu verhindern, weil die ja eigentlich für Wundheilung da sind, ne? Man hat sich verletzt und zack, da muss jetzt mal was geronnen werden. Und dann grinnt das sozusagen im Körper und verstopft halt äh,
die Venen, was dann eben zu den äh entsprechenden Problemen führt. Das ist das, was man eben auch durch die Infektion bekommen kann.
Das heißt, an der Stelle ist man jetzt nicht schlechter dran mit der Impfung.
Hätte es die Impfung nicht ausgelöst, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit wahrscheinlich gar nicht so gering, dass es auch einfach durch das Virus selbst ausgelöst wird.
Also, dass der selbe Gedanke kam mir auch wahrscheinlich die Person, die jetzt bei der Impfungsschäden davongetragen haben, da ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch,
dass die große Probleme äh äh gekriegt hätten, wenn sie sich infiziert äh hätten und vermutlich äh sogar ja gut
schlimmer als sterben, weiß ich nicht äh aber.
Ja ähm das ist zumindest stark zu vermuten
beweisen kann man's natürlich nicht, weil äh so nass ist äh.
Ja nicht feststellbar, aber ähm es spricht eigentlich alles dafür, dass es so ist.
Dass die Leute eine Infektion nicht überlebt hätten, die die Impfung nicht überlebt haben.
Also es ist natürlich jetzt eine These, die die wir jetzt hier nicht beweisen äh können, aber so.
Die ist unbeweisbar, aber ich halte das die Annahme für plausibel.
Was noch dazu kommt ist, dass ähm in der Universität Greifswald man behauptet
dass sie jetzt auch schon wüssten, was hier äh der Effekt ist, ohne dass der jetzt schon groß beschrieben worden wäre, weil ich habe bisher noch kein
PayPal dazu gesehen, das kommt wohl erst noch raus, aber da wird zu einer Pressemitteilung haben sie es immerhin schon gebracht. Keine Ahnung, was davon zu halten ist. Auf jeden Fall.
Ähm meinen sie, dass das behandelbarer Zustand ist? Und äh sieht das irgendwie schon erkannt
warum das so schnell gegangen ist, weiß ich nicht, wird im Wesentlichen damit zu tun haben, dass sie sich wahrscheinlich schon länger mit der Problematik beschäftigen. Äh ist ja nicht so, dass Thrombosen jetzt ein komplett neues Forschungsfeld werden, äh wo jetzt erst äh erstmalig dran gearbeitet wird, sondern hier.
Wird es hoffentlich demnächst auch noch weitere Erkenntnisse geben.
Ja bisher ist es ein bisschen wenig äh was ähm da verfügbar ist, aber ja, denke, hoffe, da kommt ein bisschen mehr.
So, schauen wir doch mal, wie sich denn das jetzt ausgewirkt hat. Also am wann wurden die eingestellt? Am Dienstag oder am Montag, also diese Woche auf jeden Fall, ne
und das bedeutet, dass eben viele Dosen nicht äh verimpft werden konnten. Jetzt ist es wieder angelaufen. Also
In der Folge, die Geschichte haben wir auch noch nicht ganz zu Ende erzählt, machen wir das vielleicht nochmal, also Dienstag war dann äh das Impfen eingestellt, dann gab's eine dicke fette äh Debatte äh dazu
auch Trosten hatte sich in seinem Podcast zeitnah dazu nochmal geäußert dann äh gab's halt
will der öffentliche Diskussion, dann hat sich die die IMA gemeldet, hat gesagt, äh wir schauen uns das jetzt irgendwie mal an und am Donnerstag haben sie gesagt so, hm, na ja, okay, wir haben uns das angeschaut, also
wir müssen da vielleicht nochmal eine Warnung mit in den Beipackzettel nehmen, aber es ist jetzt irgendwie nichts was unsere Grundhaltung gegenüber dem Impfstoff
ändert und man soll doch mal bitte weiter impfen und das wird halt jetzt seit Freitag auch getan. Und am Wochenende.
Sollen zumindest in Berlin und ich habe das aus anderen Bundesländern ähnlich gehört, äh sollen am Wochenende diese Impfungen, die,
nicht stattgefunden haben in der Woche möglichst nachgeholt werden und alle anderen Termine bleiben. Ich hoffe für euch ähm.
Ist da nichts ausgefallen? Ich kenne ein paar Leute.
Die jetzt diese Woche dran gewesen wären und dann entsprechend äh nicht so begeistert waren von dieser ganzen Situation
Aber das Ganze hat natürlich die äh,
Impfzahlen doch erheblich nach unten gedrängt während wir also letzte Woche schon so bei zweihundertfünfzigtausend pro Tag angekommen waren
ging's halt diese Woche dann nochmal so auf hundertsechsundsiebzigtausend, hundertachtzigtausend runter. Also
Das war jetzt kein besonders erfolgreiche Woche. Ich hoffe, dass jetzt mit den Nachholimpfungen am Wochenende zumindest es wieder eingeholt werden kann und dann äh
Na ja, dann das ist die große Hoffnung, dass so spätestens in zwei Wochen das ganze Impfgeschehen endlich mal ein bisschen Fahrt aufnimmt, weil die Kurzer,
einen kurzen Anstieg, den wir jetzt letzte Woche noch zu verzeichnen hatten, der ist natürlich jetzt erstmal wieder raus aus der ganzen Nummer.
Mehr als zehn Millionen Dosen verabreicht, acht Komma fünf Prozent in Deutschland sind mindestens erst geimpft. Das ist ja schon mal.
Ganz nett, aber wenn's halt in der Geschwindigkeit so weitergeht, dann dauert das halt einfach noch ewig, ne.
Ich meine, dann also mein ja, wenn man acht Prozent in jetzt ähm machst drei, nicht ganz drei Monaten, zweieinhalb Monaten ähm.
So ja.
Was wäre das ähm zweieinhalb Monate mal zwölf äh zweieinhalb Jahre, ja. Ungefähr würden wir in dem äh Tempo brauchen, das wir durch wären.
Ja gut, aber das Tempo wird so nicht beibehalten werden, ne? Es ist.
Nein, das ist schon klar.
Einem klar gewesen, also das zweite Quartal sollte nun wirklich Änderung bringen. Natürlich ist dann die Impfstoffmenge, die in Europa aufschlägt, immer noch nicht ausreichend, aber es wird auf jeden Fall schon mal deutlich besser. In,
Zusammenhang ist es vielleicht auch nochmal ganz interessant, mal zu schauen, warum das eigentlich so ist
ja? Also gerade wenn man jetzt in die USA schaut, da sind sie ja gerade irgendwie so richtig unterwegs, da haben die so zwei Komma vier Millionen Impfungen pro Tag. Und die impfen.
Auf Parkplätzen, die impfen in Supermärkten, die impfen äh weißt du, die impfen wie die Blöden. Und da kann man jetzt da sagen so, oha.
Was machen die denn irgendwie besser als wir? Gut, der Markt eine gewisse Kreativität sein äh,
Für wie offiziell so ein Impfzentrum oder so ein Impfort sein muss, ja? Ich glaube, da ist Deutschland so ein bisschen ähm
Mesoetepietäter und man hätte das ganz gerne schön in der Arztpraxis oder zumindest in so einem Impfzentrum und wenn jetzt hier irgendwie beim Aldi anfängst zu impfen, dann dann rumpft der Deutsche bestimmt die Nase
und meint so, na ja, aber so wollte ich mich jetzt auch nicht vor der Katastrophe retten. Ähm der wesentliche Unterschied ist der.
Die USA haben den Impfstoff und das liegt im Wesentlichen dadran, dass einerseits eine ganze Menge dort produziert wird.
Andererseits sehe auch noch Impfstoff aus dem Ausland erhalten, der im Ausland produziert wird, aber vor allem sie nichts, aber auch wirklich nichts von dem, was in den USA produziert wird.
Exportieren.
Ich bin mir da nicht ganz sicher, da müssten wir mal äh.
Nachgehen. Ich hörte, dass sie zumindest wohl nach Kanada schon was geschickt haben und nach Mexiko.
Also das ist schon und dass äh ich meine dieses Gesetz äh oder so ist ja wohl unter Trump erlassen äh worden
aber äh ja also jedenfalls das bedarf halt noch ein bisschen der Aufklärung. Ich.
Dem.
Nachgehen, ähm was denn jetzt sozusagen tatsächlich der Fall ist, ob dieses Gesetz absolut keine äh Exporte, ob das tatsächlich überhaupt noch angewandt äh wird oder gilt. Das ist möglicherweise überholt. Aber.
Es gilt. Es gilt und es wird auch noch angewandt. Es ist sogar so und ich glaube, das hat sich letzte Woche schon erwähnt, es lagert in den USA, lagert unter anderem lagern siebzig Millionen Impfdosen, Astra Sinica im Stoff.
Ja, das, das ist natürlich ein Skandal.
So, ja und der ist da noch nicht mal zugelassen. So und ähm.
Die haben einfach ganz klar die Politik, wir schicken jetzt hier erstmal gar nichts weg, bevor wir nicht fertig sind. Die wollen irgendwie am am am Forst auf
Wollen die sozusagen ihre ihr Befreiungsfest äh feiern und der beiden will verkünden, so hier Nationalfeiertag alles gut. Euer Heiland ist gekommen und ihr seid jetzt alle geimpft,
Und das werden sie wahrscheinlich sogar hinkriegen.
Und erst danach darf dann die Welt äh auch noch ein bisschen was bekommen. Jetzt ist es umgekehrt so, Europa, also die EU konkret ist der Ort auf der Welt, der am meisten Impfstoffe.
Produziert und auch am meisten in die Welt schickt.
Kann ich jetzt gerade keine belastbaren Zahlen äh zu nennen. Ich habe die äh Quelle vergeigt.
Aber und was besonders lustig ist, ist ja, dass auch die Briten gerade so verächtlich auf uns schauen
Ja, so nach dem Motto, was wollt ihr denn eigentlich hier irgendwie und und unser geiler, britischer Impfstoff, den wollt ihr jetzt hier auch noch verbieten, wie sehr hasst ihr uns eigentlich, da gibt's ja wirklich die absurdesten Diskussionen damit. Aber das ist halt Großbritannien.
Britannien bezieht irgendwie neun Millionen Impfdosen aus der EU. Die in Belgien produziert werden. Wir beziehen null Impfdosen aus Großbritannien.
Dass man nur so nebenbei. Also es ist.
Wir haben glaube ich, mit vier meine ich jetzt mal die EU so ein bisschen in so einem Highland-Modus äh ja erstmal wir wollen halt allgemein.
Dass es in der EU äh gleiche Verteilung gibt, finde ich auch völlig in Ordnung. Die Grundhaltung. Wir wollen auch ein Teil in die Welt abgeben.
Kowax in die Initiative hatte ich hier schon mal erwähnt, die äh wird damit bedacht und es gibt ja auch noch Partnerlinder, wie äh Israel und ähm also wo wo kriegt denn Israel seinen Impfstoff her?
Aus Europa.
Also dieser biontech-Impfstoff, der da äh im ganzen Land verteilt wird und sie jetzt schon auf eine Impfquote von äh weit über fünfzig Prozent gebracht hat, der kommt aus der EU.
So und das ist halt die Absurdität dieser Situation. Das wird sich verbessern und ich glaube, dass die EU jetzt auch ganz gut beraten ist, mal äh den anderen Ländern gegenüber, die halt überhaupt nicht teilen wollen, da auch eine etwas härtere Gang hat,
anzulegen.
Ja, weil am Ende ist es nämlich ein globales Problem. Also ich würde jetzt sagen, die EU nicht dafür kritisieren oder uns nicht dafür kritisieren, dass wir auch
Impfstoff äh abgeben, weil am Ende nützt was nützt es uns äh am Ende des Tages äh wenn wir alle durchgeimpft äh sind und der äh Rest halt nicht dann.
Jahr sind wir zwar erstmal geimpft und das gilt auch für die für die Amerikaner, aber wenn anderswo
dann munter neue Mutationen entstehen
dann laufen wir halt Gefahr, dass die, dass wir mit dem Impfen nochmal von vorne anfangen müssen, weil ja äh anderswo auf der Welt sich das halt munter,
dass das Virus weiterentwickelt und notiert hat und dass es auch das droht uns auch noch nach wie vor, weil
ähm ja.
Äh von daher sage ich mal, schlagen da so ein bisschen zwei Herzen in meiner Brust auf der einen Seite. Klar, natürlich möchte ich irgendwie so bald wie möglich geimpft werden und schaue natürlich.
Neidisch mittlerweile dann äh auf weiß ich nicht, Amerikaner und äh Engländer, dass das da so viel besser läuft
aber auf der anderen Seite ähm ja.
Ist das eine globale Pandemie, wenn man eine Pandemie ist eine Definition, global, also das ist eigentlich, ne? Tautologie, eine globale Pandemie. Ähm
und von daher,
Ja, aber äh ich gehe auch davon aus, dass hoffentlich wie das in,
solchen Fällen oft der Fall ist so Anfang Panik ist groß, nichts kommt und dann irgendwann wird es aber komplett
irgendwann werden wird hoffentlich dann auch die Welt und möglichst ich hoffe auch noch dieses Jahr äh entgegen aller Vorhersagen, ähm dass wir den Punkt
erreichen, äh, dass wirklich Impfstoff global in ausreichenden Mengen verfügbar ist und dass dann eher das Problem ist tatsächlich,
dann die Leute geimpft zu kriegen und,
ja anfängliche Prognosen äh waren ja, dass das Jahre dauern wird, aber ich hoffe, dass die nicht eintreffen.
Wo wir gerade von betroffenen Regionen sprechen, da muss man auf jeden Fall mal nach Brasilien zeigen, ne. Ähm
Da geht's gerade so richtig Scheiße zur Sache, ne? Also Brasilien hat eigentlich in jeder Hinsicht wirklich wirklich die schlechtesten Rahmenbedingungen. Erstmal haben sie ja noch so einen Trump
Bolsonaro, der auch wirklich alles dafür tut äh die Situation noch schlimmer werden zu lassen, als sie ohnehin schon ist. Das ist der.
Einfach mal überhaupt nicht und ich werde glaube ich bis ans Ende meines Lebens nicht verstehen, wie wie Länder nicht in der Lage sind, sich's von Volltrotteln
äh Volltrottel zu entledigen. Ja, also die werden ja dann auch immer noch gewählt und sind irgendwie pomulär und man weiß überhaupt nicht warum eigentlich
Und jetzt gibt's in Brasilien gleich mehrere Probleme. Also abgesehen davon, dass die Infektionen sowieso schon extrem hoch sind, die Todesrate extrem hoch ist. Also da sterben einfach derzeit die Leute,
wirklich äh in immer höherer Geschwindigkeit, also während es bei uns ja wirklich bergab geht
Und irgendwie halbwegs im Griff ist, äh beschleunigt sich da gerade noch die Sterberate.
Enorm und liegt ähm locker mal bei bei dem fünffachen pro per Bevölkerung,
Aber ist noch schlimmer, weil mittlerweile in fünfundzwanzig von siebenundzwanzig Großstädten oder Hauptstädten von den Bezirken, glaube ich, liegen die äh Intensivstationen bei achtzig Prozent oder mehr,
Auslastung.
Ich glaube neunzehn von siebenundzwanzig sogar war neunzig Prozent, also äh wollten die Krankenhäuser sind voll. Die Leute stehen draußen, sterben quasi in der Warteschlange, ist alles ganz furchtbar. Und ähm ja, weil noch alles
Immer schlimmer werden kann, das hat's ja gerade angesprochen, ne. Wir haben halt in.
In Brasilien einfach jetzt die die härteste Variante von Covit in Form dieser P1 Variante.
P eins ist offensichtlich zwei bis zweieinhalb Mal so ansteckend wie der Wildtyp, wie Corona Classic.
Also nochmal extrem viel mehr als äh jetzt dieses B eins eins sieben.
Und das ist halt genau das, was ich gerade in Brasilien irgendwie breit macht und äh ja.
Ist dem so. Also ich habe jetzt noch wenig Zahlen äh dazu äh gesehen hattest du da äh äh was, also mit dem sagen zweieinhalb.
Mal ansteckender als der Wildtyp kommt mir sehr krass vor.
Ja, meine Quelle ist jetzt hier wie der Twitterfeed von diesem, von der ja auch schon öfter erwähnten Erik
Ding, der äh wird nicht müde über die Situation in in Brasilien zu berichten und äh Reit am laufenden Meter böse Paper und äh so weiter äh an. Da habe ich jetzt irgendwie
diese Zahl her, also hier gibt's eine Studie, ich kann hier auch nochmal explizit verlinken,
Aber hier ist halt explizit davon die Rede, dass.
Dass die P1 Variante, genau hier ist dieses Model Base Invalibation of Transmissibility and Real Infection Rate, also auch die Reenfektionsrate ist sehr viel höher, also gegenüber.
Als sieben ist es irgendwie sechzig Prozent nochmal schlimmer, also schneller.
Uns ist halt auch von einer höheren Reinfektionsrate äh die Rede, also das irgendwie Leute, die schon sich vorher mit dem Virus mit einer anderen Variante äh infiziert haben, dann nochmal neu infiziert werden durch die P1 Variante.
Ja, ich seh's gerade sechs Komma vier Prozent, sagen wir bisher mit der alten Variante infizierten, wurden nochmal, äh, haben sich nochmal mit P eins angesteckt, haben das sozusagen.
Noch ein zweites Mal äh eine zweite Infektion dann wohl durchgemacht. Ja.
Ja und P eins äh haben wir hier und da auch in Deutschland schon, aber noch nicht in bedrohlichen Mengen, aber ich habe jetzt auch davon gehört, dass es in Mallorca auch schon äh ist und da freue ich mich doch schon auf unseren ganzen Mallorca-Urlauber, die dann Ostern, äh weil sie in Deutschland noch kein Campingplatz finden.
In Mallorca schön tummeln und sich mal richtig schön frei fühlen und dann wahrscheinlich hier wieder mit den geilen äh Quarantänenregelungen von Deutschland zurückkommen, so nach dem Motto, ja, ach so, sie kommen gerade aus Mallorca, ne?
Dann bleiben sie mal vierzehn Tage zu Hause für dich. So, das war's. Machen dann die Leute nicht.
Gut, am Ende wird's jetzt spannend äh werden.
Hab da jetzt leider auch noch keine neuen Zahlen nochmal auf die Suche machen, wie sich denn jetzt P eins im Wettbewerb mit P eins eins sieben verhält, da kommt,
müsste wahrscheinlich mal nach England äh gucken, wie sich das da wie die sich.
Dort relativ zueinander entwickeln. Das wäre das, da müssten die Zahlen da sein, dass werde ich mal äh.
Für die nächste Sendung versuchen, rauszufinden, weil das ist natürlich ja interessante Frage, ein interessantes Problem.
Und wir hatten ja neulich auch die Diskussion wie viel schlimmer kann's denn noch werden? Also
ähm so anfangs war's ja so
also eine, als es neu war im letzten Jahr hieß es erstmal, war die Einschätzung der Verologen auch. Das ist so gut angepasst, das Virus jetzt ist es so optimal
es ist eher unwahrscheinlich, dass das Virus noch.
Besser wird, also besser im Sinne von erfolgreicher und schlimmer so. Und dann.
Kam halt B eins eins sieben so
Wir haben festgestellt, okay, das war jetzt noch nicht das Ende der Fahnenstange und dann gab's dann halt auch wieder eine Annahme, okay, aber jetzt jetzt so viel besser kann's jetzt nicht mehr werden
und äh sagen jetzt äh mit Wind P eins tatsächlich dann nochmal ja nochmal erfolgreicher, noch besser angepasst ist, ist die Frage, ist das jetzt das Beste, was die Natur
uns äh ähm entgegenwerfen wird oder kann äh so
da gibt es viele Experten, dass äh die sagen auch, ich meine, ich glaube sogar Drosten hatte sagen auch die
Möglichkeit zumindest erwähnt, dass da äh sagen nicht mehr so viel Platz ist äh für neue Motationen hat.
Auch was.
Ja also Corona Virus äh Update, Podcast diese Woche mit ihm war ganz äh interessant, weil er genau diese Frage eigentlich auch nochmal aufs Tableau gestellt hat und wenn ich ihn richtig verstanden habe.
Ist die milde Hoffnung, die er mit der Situation äh verbindet, der Gestalt, dass.
Wird zwar jetzt diese
auf Konzernen gesehen haben, also B eins eins sieben, England, B dreizehn einundfünfzig, Südafrika, P eins, Brasilien
zwei, wo ich jetzt die Nummer nicht weiß in New York und äh oder nochmal zwei in Kalifornien oder so. Das sind so im Wesentlichen so die die Varianten, die derzeit ähm sich manifestieren in größeren Communitys und die äh,
mehr oder weniger, mehr Transmessibilität und gegebenenfalls auch Litalität an den Tag legen. Also die quasi erkennbar hier so ein neuer Phenotyp sind und ähm,
bedrohlich sind, aber Varianten und Mutationen sind ja zwei verschiedene Dinge. Also eine Variante entsteht.
In dem ein oder mehrere nennenswerte Mutationen auftreten und die dann bleiben,
Ja? Und an den man primär diese Änderung im Verhalten auch festmachen kann.
Also eine Mutter ist quasi eine einzige Stelle und das sind eben sowas wie dieses E vier acht vier K,
Ja, weil das bedeutet eben, wo vorher ein Eh
eine E-Aminosäure kodiert war an der Stelle vier acht vier, da ist jetzt eine K Aminosäure äh kodiert, ne? Mal so die einfache Beschreibung. Und wir haben jetzt so verschiedene dieser Abkürzungen gesehen. Diese fünfhunderteins Y und äh kriegst du jetzt gerade alle nicht drauf
aber alle diese Varianten.
Haben sich unertappt, unabhängig voneinander entwickelt, die stehen nicht in in einer, in einer Vererbungshierarchie.
Trotzdem haben die alle mehr oder weniger aus dem selben Pool von Mutationen, also sowohl an derselben Stelle als auch dieselbe Art von Mutation äh sich bedient.
Und das ist halt ganz interessant, weil das könnte wohl gemerkt, jetzt hier wieder konjunktiv und Einschränkungen und so weiter. Das könnte darauf hinweisen.
Dass das dann eben vielleicht auch schon das ganze Arsenal ist, weil das jetzt so eine Mutation gezielt ist.
Ist sie nicht. Eine Mutation tritt auf, das ist eine Mutation ist ein entweder ein Kopierfeder oder einen seltensten Fällen, ist da vielleicht nochmal äh irgendwie etwas Röntgenstrahlung äh dazwischen gekommen. Aber im Wesentlichen ist es halt.
Kopierfehler, der stattfindet und das Virus saß Kopf zwei hat ja auch noch so einen so ein so eine.
Reparaturmechanism.
So ein Reparaturmechanis, so eine Fehlerkorrektur ähm beim Kopieren, keine Ahnung, wie das genau funktioniert. Also die ist eh so ein bisschen drauf äh bedacht, äh sie selbst zu bleiben,
trotzdem setzen sich halt manche Mutationen eben durch und manifestieren sich dann in diesen Varianten. Aber alle diese Varianten
alle verschiedene Kombinationen der selben Motationen durch.
Grob betrachtet und das könnte bedeuten, dass die Anpassungsfähigkeit dieses Virus, was ja an sich.
Der König der Anpassungsfähigkeit an den Menschen ist.
In dieser spezifischen Disziplin mit hier ACE zwei Rezeptoren. Das ganze Klimmbim ans Ende.
Scheint. Das das sozusagen egal was es jetzt hier randommäßig weltweit so ausprobiert in großen Populationen, in großen naiven
Population dieses Virus noch nicht gesehen haben, wo sie sich wirklich ordentlich austanzen kann, noch immer noch enorme Zuwachstumsraten hat,
nicht auf eine bessere Idee kommt, dass das sozusagen die anderen Mutationen nicht passen.
Die These ist sozusagen, dass der Raum an Mut hat.
An äh möglichen oder erfolgreichen Mutationen jetzt sozusagen durchgesampelt ist, weil was sozusagen das Virus macht im Prinzip ist,
oder des Virus macht es nicht, sondern es passiert halt einfach ähm so dass mehr oder weniger zufällige Varianten.
Äh generiert werden und ausprobiert werden und sagen die Hoffnung ist, dass äh wir sagen jetzt alle erfolgreichen Varianten schon mal durchprobiert worden.
Oder ist es zumindest nicht so nicht mehr so viele gibt. Ja, also es kann schon sein, dass noch welche anschauen. Aber dass die eigentlich alle mit denselben Mutationen letzten Endes arbeiten,
Und auf der anderen Seite muss man ja auch sehen, um mal hier ein bisschen Optimismus auch wieder reinzubringen. Die Impfstoffe, die wir haben,
sind somit die ziemlich die besten Impfstoffe, die es überhaupt jemals gab als Impfstoffe. Es gab.
Gegen andere Krankheiten auch Impfstoffe, aber es gab nicht so viele so effiziente Impfstoffe.
Diese ganzen Wirkungsgrade, die wir jetzt hier die letzten Wochen runtergebetet haben, ja? Wie schnell die schon nach einer ersten Impfung.
Tod verhindern, schwere Krankheit verhindern und wie wir jetzt wissen, sogar auch Reinfektion, also und Neuinfektionen, also überhaupt Infektionität verhindern.
Das es anhört auf. Wir haben also Glück im Unglück.
Wir haben hier einen Virus, der soll's super an den Menschen angepasst ist, der auch.
Dummerweise die richtige Balance zwischen Transmissibilität und Letalität findet, ja, wäre er letaler.
Hätten wir sehr viel mehr dagegen getan. Aber so reicht's immer noch, dass Leute rumlaufen und sagen, gibt's gar nicht.
Ja, ist aber trotzdem total unangenehm und und und kann halt wirklich,
äh äh krank machen und nervt und verbreitet sich auch noch bekloppt schnell. Also er ist wirklich super, super in super Nische vorgedrungen, so eine biologische Nische, die der Mensch offen gelassen hat,
aber die die Keule, die wir jetzt ausgepackt haben, die ist so krass, dass wenn wir jetzt alle impfen.
Das wäre schon wirklich ein Teil des Problems, damit erschlagen. Also wir bremsen die Infektion sehr schnell und in dem Moment vielleicht noch ein ein Satz, in dem Moment, wo wir die.
Die dritte Dosis sozusagen, an der jetzt auch gearbeitet wird, komme ich gleich nochmal zu. Dann auch noch nachreichen, um dann eben auch noch so die letzten erfolgreichen Varianten äh auch noch mit wegzufegen
ab dem Moment kann man vielleicht sagen, dass wir dann wirklich auf der Siegerstraße sind.
Ja, ich hoffe ja, dass äh Professor Drosten in dem Fall Recht behält mit seiner Hoffnung. Ähm.
Ich muss,
nur leider sagen, ich meine, meistens bin ich ja mit ihm einer Meinung und ich höre mir auch äh in der Regel immer sehr genau an, was er sagt und kann mich auch an viele Sachen, die er gesagt hat, auch noch sehr gut
erinnern und was jetzt das Thema Mutation.
Angeht, muss ich äh sagen, äh kann ich ihm jetzt nicht den allerbesten Dreckrekord äh bescheinigen, was so Prognosen äh angeht. Wie gesagt, fachlich äh so äh ist er da sicherlich.
Irgendwie hundert Mal informierter äh äh als ich, aber wir reden halt hier von Wahrscheinlichkeiten äh was denn passieren könnte, weil sie wirklich.
Überblicken, äh, kann man das halt nicht und anfangs so.
Weiß ich, sagte er na ja wegen der Selbstkorrekturmechanismen und so ist das eigentlich ein relativ stabiles Virus und wir haben erstmal jetzt so von Mutationen erstmal halt.
Keine äh große Gefahr zu erwarten. Klar, mag sein, dass er äh damals nur so eine Zeithorizont von Monaten äh gemeint hat, aber auf jeden Fall,
ist halt auch faktisch nichts passiert in Deutschland um sich des Themas Mutation irgendwie anzunehmen auch dann.
Erst,
eigentlich als die Engländer das bemerkt haben äh und das Thema im Dezember auf den Tisch äh äh gebracht haben, haben wir überhaupt angefangen, so richtig zu suchen,
äh sagt der Torsten, auch na ja, weiß nicht, sein Budget irgendwie für äh Sequenzierung äh ist hal,
eigentlich nach zwei Wochen aufgebraucht, wenn man äh in den ersten zwei Wochen des Jahres aufgebraucht, wenn man äh so viel sequenzieren würde, dass man wirklich einen guten Überblick hat
und dementsprechend ja so kamen wir da halt relativ.
Spät ähm so äh hin uns dieses Problems anzunehmen und dann.
Ist es halt auch noch so, äh dass zumindest äh also es,
sind ganz, ganz viele Änderungen möglich. Ich habe da ja auch mal in einem, in einem Sweat äh zu beschrieben, was sich denn alles verändern kann, wenn so ein Virus motiert und.
Klar, die Frage ist, ist es auch wahrscheinlich unmöglich und wird es passieren, aber äh,
am Ende gibt es noch so viele Stellschrauben, äh die das Virus.
Auch noch haben könnte, also um jetzt also ja es ist möglich und ich hoffe äh äh dass das Virus so jetzt.
Dass es so ist wie Drosten sagt und das Virus ähm ja äh langsam.
Ihm die Ideen ausgehen, sage ich mal, salopp, äh aber
so meine Befürchtung ist ein bisschen das da noch mehr kommen könnte von dem wir noch nicht wissen so diese sagen das.
Also ich meine was seine Prognosen betrifft bezüglich der Muttertion, ich meine das war halt,
wäre sicherlich ganz wertvoll sich nochmal die Aussagen im Detail anzuhören, aber soweit ich mich da erinnern kann, war es erstmal grundsätzlich die Aussage, Corona Viren, mutieren nicht in dem selben Maße, wie es zum Beispiel HIV oder Influencer tun,
Da ist das ein echtes Problem und das ist halt auch das, was vor allem eben diese effektiven Impfungen, dauerhafte Impfungen bisher verhindert hat,
bei HIV halt eigentlich gänzlich und bei bei Grippe muss halt immer wieder nachgeliefert werden. Das ist halt einfach eine Eigenschaft von Corona Viren, wie man sie bisher,
kannte
und das gilt in gewisser Hinsicht wohl auch noch für Saaskurv zwei, das andere ist, was man eben zu welchem Zeitpunkt man das erwartet, ne? Also jetzt sind wir halt einfach noch
auf der ganzen Welt,
mit diesem Virus noch nicht in Verbindung gekommen und wie wir ja mittlerweile wissen, ist die Tatsache, dass man mit anderen Chorona-Viren in Verbindung gekommen ist, er ist kein besonderer Schutz
Von daher gibt's halt einfach naive Bevölkerung und solange das Ding halt einfach nirgendswo gegenstößt kann es halt sich einfach,
weiter äh anpassen so und letztlich damit können wir den Bereich vielleicht auch mal äh beenden. Trotzdem.
Ist das, was wir sozusagen an Anzahl an Varianten gesehen haben. Nichts, was wir nicht umgehen könnten.
Schwierigkeit mit dem Umgang haben wir derzeit nur in der eigentlichen Ausbreitung der Infektion. Da sind wir halt schlecht drin. So, aber wir haben die Mittel, das Ding medizinisch.
Zu stoppen und müssen es ist halt nur hochskalieren.
Sehr wahrscheinlich, so sieht es im Moment äh aus, aber äh,
Der Punkt ist, äh wir haben halt äh das Virus,
auch noch nicht so richtig oder wir wir haben das Virus zwar schon an verschiedenen Stellen ja einen evolutionären Druck ausgeübt.
Auf das Virus, also
eine ja Selektion sozusagen durchgeführt und ähm was wir noch nicht genau wissen ist
wenn wir jetzt mit den Impfungen halt Druck ausüben
wie weit das Virus dann doch in dem Moment, wo wir ihm jetzt auf die Füße treten oder sagen wir so, wo jetzt,
Varianten, die gegen den Impfstoff helfen.
Sich nicht weiter verbreiten, aber dann vielleicht etwas weniger virulent Varianten, die ohne Impfstoff,
keine Chance hätten unter Bedingungen des Impfstoffs, weil sie eben dann
in der Lage sind den zu umgehen, ähm dass sie ja dann sich trotzdem ausbreiten oder oder
entwickeln können, sodass das sehe ich halt äh immer noch als ja sogar
eher wahrscheinlich
an, weil wir wir werden's wahrscheinlich an Israel, wobei Israel sind halt wenig Leute, aber am schlimmsten dürfte es sein, dann in Ländern, wo gleichzeitig, wo geimpft wird und gleichzeitig wo Insedenz herrscht. Gut, das ist in Israel, glaube ich, immer noch der Fall
ist eigentlich eben für für sowas glaube ich ungünstig ähm einfach allmählich
in so 'ne Population reinzuimpfen wo halt noch viel Virus da ist. Das ist halt nicht gut. Eigentlich willst du wenn du anfängst zu impfen
es so schnell wie möglich machen äh und alle durchimpfen und den Virus nicht allzu lange die Möglichkeit zu geben, auf neue Ideen zu kommen, um die Impfung zu umgehen
ja so sehe ich das, aber gut, ich bin jetzt, wie gesagt, auch kein Bierologe, aber ähm.
Ja, wir werden sehen, werden sehen. Leider sind halt, das macht mir halt ein bisschen Angst, dass Zeit äh ganz viele meiner Befürchtungen äh immer wieder eingetreten sind. Ähm,
und ich hoffe, dass das in dem Fall nicht passiert.
Gut, dann.
Wollte ich an dieser Stelle nochmal kurz erwähnen, wo wir gerade bei bösen Varianten sind. Es gab ja auch noch die ähm diesen Bericht, dass es jetzt auch noch eine blöde Variante aus Frankreich gibt, die sich äh den Tests entzieht,
Ich glaube, das hatten wir auch in der letzten, das hat sie, glaube ich, in der letzten Folge auch kurz so als These in den Raum gestellt, dass sowas ja auch noch kommen könnte.
Ist passiert äh und zwar in Frankreich. Allerdings und das gleich mal vorweg. Es handelt sich hier erstmal nicht oder
wahrscheinlich auch überhaupt nicht äh um eine Variante auf Konzernen, diese VOC, über die wir jetzt schon so viel
haben, sondern dass es schlicht eine Investigation, das ist sozusagen die die Unterscheidung, also es gibt hier kein Konzern, man hat hier irgendwie keine besondere Angst, aber man stellt halt fest, es gibt hier eine Variante, die sich irgendwie anders verhält und in dem Fall war es halt so, dass die eben in Frankreich den PCR-Tests entkommen ist
Das ist jetzt kein besonders
dramatischer Vorgang. Also zunächst einmal das ist also es gibt nichts, was darauf hinweist, dass es sich hier um eine transmisiblere.
Oder gar tödlichere Variante des Virus handelt.
Sondern sie hat sich einfach nur auf eine Art und Weise mutiert an den Stellen, wo halt die PCR-Tests, die dort in Frankreich zum Einsatz kam, nicht getestet haben.
Oder beziehungsweise nein, sie ist genau an den Stellen notiert, wo äh drauf getestet wurde, ne, weil BCR-Test.
Schaut sich nicht das komplette Genom an, sondern man sucht bestimmte Stellen und sagt, wenn man die Kombination finden,
Diese drei zum Beispiel, das ist glaube ich so eine typische Zahl, dass man so drei verschiedene Stellen werden gesuch
die werden dann sozusagen repliziert und wenn da halt äh sich was bei äh vermehrt, ne, dann weiß man, okay, okay, das war dann halt da. Wenn.
Aber nun genau diese drei äh Kombinationen im Genom sich mutieren.
Dann kann dieser Test natürlich nichts finden. So hat man ja auch am Anfang nochmal so als Erinnerung äh
in England die Ausbreitung von B eins eins sieben gefunden. Nicht weil man explizit darauf getestet oder ähm.
Sequenziert hätte, sondern weil der Test, der zum Einsatz kam, so eine Austastlücke hatte. Also sie haben einfach gesehen, dass äh die positiven Meldungen waren so, weil zwei Genomen wurden gefunden und eins nicht, weil sie sich.
SS Jean Target Falia SGTF ist mittlerweile so ein feststehender Begriff
auch in der englischen Korona äh Literatur der Statistiken, da findet man dann oft so SGTF basiert und das ist genau äh das eben, ja.
Aber an sich jetzt äh da deswegen müsstet ihr müsst ihr jetzt nicht äh schlechter schlafen als ohnehin schon. Das ist jetzt eigentlich eher so eine Kleinigkeit.
Genau, nur nur weil's da sonst Dells Virus äh äh gibt, was irgendwie.
Sich unter dem Radar wegtu.
Was ich unter dem Radar bewegt beziehungsweise ja äh sagen äh Counter, ja, Countdown Masures äh äh gegen,
Testdetektion oder wie auch immer, ja
Wie wahrscheinlich ist es, ist es nicht so das Problem, weil in dem Moment, wo halt ein Haufen Leute anfangen irgendwie an äh Symptomen zu leiden und äh die genau aussehen, wie.
Ja saß,
äh zwei dann äh und die Tests und die testen aber negativ äh ist das, was was dann schon äh ja auffällt. So insofern ist der Vorteil, den das Virus dadurch hat.
Nicht allzu groß aber ja.
Genau,
So, dann habe ich noch äh aus der Abteilung gute Nachrichten. Ähm gibt's nämlich auch eine neue äh Studie, die besagt, dass es hier bei einer Frau, die in der sechsunddreißigsten Schwangerschaftswoche geimpft wurde.
Drei Wochen später war dann die Geburt ihres Kindes, dass bei dieser Frau äh Antikörper sich nicht nur in der Frau gebildet haben, sondern dann auch.
Bei dem Neugeborenen gefunden wurden. Und eine andere Studie hat auch schon mal Antikörper in Muttermilch nachgewiesen, die von einer.
Bin mir jetzt grad nicht ganz so sicher, ob das von der Infektion war oder ob das von einer Impfung war, aber auf jeden Fall in diesem Fall war es explizit so.
Die Frau wurde geimpft und während der Schwangerschaft, ja, gut,
Und äh es ist ja generell so, dass eben Mütter ihren Neugeborenen solange sie im Bauch sind und äh verbunden sind halt diverses Antikörpermaterial mit auf den Weg geben,
So funktioniert das ja generell und offensichtlich gehören die Antikörper gegen das Bike-Protein. Auch dazu. Was man nicht weiß.
Ist, ob jetzt dieser Antikörper ausreichend sind, eine Infektion zu verhindern, das ist etwas, was sicherlich erst sehr viel später äh festgestellt werden wird, wenn überhaupt
aber trotzdem ist das schon mal eine ganz gute Nachricht. So, dann habe ich noch einen Tipp für einen Film.
Äh und zwar gibt's beim ZDF ein Filmchen.
So ein 3D animiertes Filmchen, das heißt Viviren, unseren Körper angreifen.
Und da würde ich euch mal raten, da ein bisschen Zeit äh zu investieren. Viel Zeit ist auch nicht erforderlich. Das Ding ist äh eine Dreiviertelstunde lang,
Aber das ist komplett 3D animiert und ist eine Reise in die Zelle,
und es ist wirklich mega. Also es ist äh an dieser Stelle ist es allerdings nicht, dass das Kopf zwei Virus, was hier äh vorgestellt wird, sondern das sind die Adenovieren.
Aber das ist auch ganz praktisch, weil da kann man mal sehen, wie die Adenovieren, die ja zum Beispiel bei Astraceca, ne, zum Einsatz äh kommen oder bei Sputnik äh V. Ja
die quasi dann so auch als Transporthülle gebraucht werden, um letzten Endes,
dass äh zu reproduzierende Spike Proteinmaterial, diese Bauvorschrift in den Körper zu bekommen.
Und es ist wirklich geil, weil sie bis ins allerletzte Detail genau zeigen
wie die Viren sich in den Zellen bewegen, wie sie an diesen strengen, langen Marschieren, wie sie von äh anderen Abwehrmechanismen außerhalb der Zelle
von Antikörpern außerhalb der Zelle, aber von auch von anderen Bekämpfungsmechanismen innerhalb der Zelle attackiert werden
wiederum da herauswinden, welche Tricks sie anwenden und also wirklich zahlreiche Tricks, das ist wirklich wie ein Krimi
dabei zuzuschauen, wie so ein Virus letzten Endes es schafft, das Unmögliche zu tun, nämlich in diese Zell,
Kerne einzudringen, wo sie am Ende viel zu groß für sind zum Beispiel, ja? Und das, das ist äh eine kolossal schöne Animation und macht
hat mir zumindest nochmal so einiges deutlich gemacht, was ich bisher nur so theoretisch verstanden hatte.
Ja, muss ich mir unbedingt angucken, mir auch spannend. Ich meine, wir hatten ja, glaube ich, auch mal erwähnt, Anfang äh.
Der Sendungsreihe äh sage ich mal
ja vor, ich weiß nicht, zehn Jahren oder so mal einen Blogartikel äh zum zu einer Studie über das Golfkriegssyndrom
geredet habe, wo auch Impfungen damals in den Verdacht geraten sind, da habe ich halt die Scansit, da habe ich halt diese hundertvierzig Seiten lange Studie mir äh angeguckt.
Durchgearbeitet und es war wirklich auch ein super,
spannendes Thema mit wirklich krassen äh äh Dingen. Also das Krasseste, was ich dann gefunden hatte, um den Zusammenhang Golfkriegssyndrom war, irgendwie das Burning Seamen Syndrom,
dass halt äh dann Frauen von Golfkriegsrückkehrern keinen Geschlechtsverkehr mehr mit ihren Männern wollten, weil äh halt irgendwie
angeblich deren Samenflüssigkeit plötzlich toxisch geworden war. Ja ähm.
Ja unklar, aber ja jedenfalls in dem Zusammenhang habe ich halt das ganze Thema irgendwie Workverstärker, äh so Quecksilber äh äh beziehungsweise Aluminium äh äh Quecksilber als Konservierungs äh Stoff dann so umstrittenes Qualin
sagen als als Workverstärker und so
also vor zehn Jahren schon mal das Ganze gestreift und habt da eben auch so eine äh ja kleine äh Reise durch das Immunsystem
gemacht und nochmal mein Schulwissen damals auf den neuesten Stand gebracht, weil er hat sich ja wirklich wirklich viel getan und ich glaube in den letzten zehn Jahren hat sich auch nochmal richtig, wirklich, wirklich viel getan, aber allein
das, was also bekannt ist, wie du richtig sagst, es ist unglaublich.
Was da im Körper alles vorgeht mit welcher Raffinesse und dieses Immunsystem ist also wie so ein Staat für sich mit Polizeitruppen, mit ähm wie
mit Fabriken, mit Entwicklungslabors für Immun äh äh für neue Anti-Cover.
Also Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn und allein was in der Zelle, auch ich weiß nicht wie ich hab den Film leider noch nicht gesehen aber was so
an Organellen in so einer Zelle noch rumschwimmt, also eine Zelle für sich ist ja schon mal ein
wirklich krass komplexer Organismus und ja also ich werd's, werde ihn mir auf jeden Fall anschauen, sobald ich Zeit.
Dafür finde, klingt spannend.
Mich hat's total an Star Wars erinnert, ne? Also da hast ja dann immer so diese Pferdenplaneten, wo dann
so auf der Oberfläche dann schwirren da so tausend Flugzeuge rum und irgendwie die ganze Zeit ist irgendwie was los und überall wird alles mögliche überprüft und es gibt so Patrouillen und Kontrollen und fliegende Autos und hast nicht gesehen und so ein bisschen ist das in diesem Film halt auch, ne? Also du bist da verdient
gefühlten Unendlichkeit einer Zelle, ist halt alles super mega klein und dieses äh Virus kommt da einfach so rein, ist auch selbst überhaupt
nicht beweglich, ja? Das kann ja gar nichts tun, ja? Das ist sozusagen
nur durch zahlreiche Tricks lässt es sich einfach von irgendwelchen Proteinen abholen, die das dann irgendwie an irgendwelchen Strängen entlang marschieren lassen und so weiter. Also es ist wirklich äh spannend und ähm geht hier auch im Wesentlichen nicht um Impfstoffe, ne, muss ich nochmal sagen, sondern es geht,
kret um den normalen äh Befall mit einem Adenovirus und äh ja, das ist auf jeden Fall sehr unterhaltsam.
Ist noch bis vierundzwanzigsten dritten angeblich verfügbar. Also fix ran. So, was ist die Frage?
Ja zappeln die denn rum oder sind die eher ruhig die ganzen Viren oder Moleküle oder was auch immer man da ähm.
Dann sieht, also wie, wie unruhig ist das Ganze? Würde mich noch interessieren.
Ähm.
Visualisierung.
Weil's jetzt die Bilder dieser Visualisierung oder meinst du das Virus selbst.
Die Bilder dieser Visualisierung, weil äh so mein, mein mentales Bild jetzt äh so wie das ist
halt dadurch die die ganzen Moleküle, das vibriert natürlich alles die ganze Zeit mit einer relativ hohen Frequenz auch
und äh also ja aufgrund eben der der Temperatur und das ist eben auch das, was dann
letztlich die ganzen Vorgänge befördert, weil äh halt das Zeug, also die Moleküle liegen da nicht rum, sondern die zapfeln und hüpfen in der Gegend rum und ab und zu
hüpfen sie dann mal irgendwo in die Nähe eines anderen Moleküls und durch die entsprechenden dann ja.
Elektrischen Felder, äh die dann herrschen, dockt dann was an oder faltet sich was zusammen oder klappt was äh zu. Das ist sozusagen.
Die die Basis dieser ganzen Vorgänge, weil ja so ein Molekül nicht so wie ein wie ein Muskel ist oder so ein so ein äh ja so ein Virus hat er jetzt keine Muskeln, mit denen es irgendwas tut,
ähm so oder irgendwie Arme und Beine, äh die es jetzt selber bewegen könnte. Ähm.
Sondern ja das geht halt letztlich alles äh ja durch durch Temperatur und äh,
elektrische Felder äh.
Also wenn du da jetzt auch noch eine eine Vielzahl von quantenmechanischen Effekten.
Dir wünschen würdest, dann muss es sich wahrscheinlich eher enttäuschen. An der Stelle ist es sehr funktional. Auf der anderen Seite wird eben auch äh klar gemacht, wie sehr eben das Virus von der Aktivität anderer Proteine abhängig ist, ne.
Ist auf jeden Fall auch in Ordnung, so eine so eine Sicht. Ich wollt's nur sagen, weil weil ich hatte das auch nicht vermutet, dass das so sein würde.
So aber ja weil ich hatte mir irgendwann neulich auch mal so ein paar Open Source äh
ähm Software zur
Visualisierung von ja Molekulardynamik im Wesentlichen mal runtergeladen, weil ich erstmal so ein bisschen mal einfache chemische Reaktionen auf molekularer Ebene mal ein bisschen mit rumspielen wollte, aber
so die.
Lernkurve ist halt steil und ich erzähle noch nicht genug Zeit mich dann wirklich ein äh zu arbeiten. Aber das ist irgendwie auch auf jeden Fall,
ja coole Möglichkeiten, was man so mittlerweile.
Definitiv in der Kategorie geil sich das anzuschauen, aber man hat danach fast noch mehr Fragen als vorher, aber das finde ich ja manchmal auch äh ganz gut, dass man dann äh neue Anknüpfungs,
Punkte hat die ähm ja wo man dann irgendwie eintauchen kann. Also es ist auf jeden Fall sehr unterhaltsam und ich,
würde euch raten, dass mal fix äh runterzuladen bis zum vierundzwanzigsten dritten ist es angeblich offen. Warum auch immer wir in Deutschland öffentlich-rechtlichen Content vom Internet nehmen müssen,
aber das ist ein anderes Problem.
Internet wird sonst zu voll.
Das.
Wird's uns zu voll, es geht nicht. Wir k.
Das ist eine tolle Erklärung
So, ich würde auch gerne ähm zu Ende kommen, möchte aber gerne hier noch ein paar News ähm runterklappern, damit das mal gesagt wurde.
Ähm also grundsätzlich kurzer Blick nach Israel, da gibt's eine neue Studie, die verlinke ich, wo nochmal umfangreicher
betrachtet wird, was sich denn so bisher aus dieser Impfkampagne alles so ergeben hat. Spoiler sieht ganz gut aus, also es ist sozusagen einfach eine Menge
an positiven Entwicklungen bei rausgekommen und grundsätzlich zeigt sich immer mehr
wie stark äh der Biontech-Impfstoff hier in allen Altersgruppen
die Hospitalisierung und die schweren Fälle verhindert und äh auch Neuinfektionen verhindert, will euch jetzt hier nicht bezahlen. Vollbomben, aber ich verlinke,
mal auf das PayPal, ja? Hast du äh da gleich was rausgezogen in der kurzen.
Ja ja, na ja, die, du hattest da ja diese, wie sagt diese schöne.
Grafik und da kann man äh schon mal sagen, dass jetzt mittlerweile bei in der Altersgruppe sechzig Plus die Hospitalisierungsrate
um siebzig Prozent zurückgegangen. Es ging.
Vom Piek.
Von Piek aus, genau, also vom Höhepunkt, also der und der war irgendwann Anfang äh des Jahres erreicht, wenn ich das richtig.
Ja, Mitte Januar. Mhm.
So. Und dann gab's halt gleichzeitig einen Lokdown und äh ja also
weißt du zufällig wie hoch die Impfvote ist, gerade bei sechzig plus in Israel, die hatten ja immer so eine nette Grafik, aber ist egal jedenfalls
ja minus siebzig Prozent heißt aber so bei sechzig plus so
ja müssen dann trotzdem noch dreißig Prozent derjenigen aus welchen Gründen auch immer ins.
Äh oder ja dreißig Prozent derer, die vorher ins Krankenhaus mussten, auf den Peak äh müssen auch immer noch ins Krankenhaus anteilsmäßig. Also es ist jetzt nicht auf null zurückgegangen und.
Ja in den und,
Es gibt Rückgang in allen Altersgruppen so ähm bei der darunter so fünfzig bis neunundfünfzig sind's um die dreißig Prozent, die die zurückgegangen sind, so bei den,
vierzig bis neunundvierzigjährigen um fünfundzwanzig Prozent und die Jungen als junge Altersgruppe um zwanzig Prozent, also,
Ja, man sieht halt dann, äh, dass es vor allem,
Altersgruppen eine eine Wirkung hat, ansonsten ja.
Ist aber die wird die positive Nachricht auf der einen Seite. Es geht überall runter in allen Altersgruppen. So richtig gesagt hast, aber
was man auch nicht erwarten darf, das kann man in Israel sehen, das das irgendwie in null Zeit auf null geht, ja,
Also da ist immer noch da ist immer noch Infektion bisher A. Äh und.
Mittlerweile ja.
Die Zahlen rausgesucht, also neunzig plus zu fünfundneunzig Prozent.
Schon geimpft mit der zweiten Impfung, erste Impfung fast achtundneunzig Prozent, wenn ich das richtig sehe bei achtzig bis neunzig ist es im Prinzip fast genauso siebzig auch, also man kann sagen.
Siebzig Plus ist zu fünfundneunzig Prozent und sechzig Plus ist so ja.
Achtzig, zweiundachtzig, fünfundachtzig Prozent hier. Ich habe hier nur Balken, deswegen kann ich's nur raten, aber die die,
durch Impfung der äh älteren Semester ist schon sehr groß, würde sagen, die liegt mal so grob bei sechzig plus der ganze sechzig Plus Bereich, liegt auf jeden Fall so bei neunzig Prozent. Aber
Hospitalisierung heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass das dann auch zu Tod und schweren Fällen führt, ne, sondern dass sozusagen nur Komplikationen
sind und das natürlich bei älteren Leuten dann äh auch tendenziell natürlich, selbst wenn's dann nicht ganz so schlimm kommt, sind die natürlich auch so schneller im Krankenhaus, weil die natürlich einfach gebrechlicher sind
Gut, aber es zeichnet sich einfach ab und es ist eigentlich alles, was ich sagen wollte, es bestätigt sich weiterhin die Ergebnisse dieser Impfstoff äh Kampagne in Israel zeigen, Impfstoff der Biotech in Prof zumindest funktioniert.
Super und schützt äh zu vierundneunzig Prozent auch ähm.
Vor asymptomatischen Infektionen. Das ist nämlich äh auch noch so eine Information, die sie rausgebracht haben, also das war ja lange Zeit so eine Frage
Wie gut ist denn der Impfstoff eigentlich jetzt ähm bei Leuten.
Äh die asymptomatisch sind und ja hier.
Wird von vierundneunzig Prozent Wirksamkeit bei der Verhinderung asymptomatischer Infektionen. Also, wo noch nicht mal eine Krankheit.
Entsteht, aber man trotzdem infiziert ist. Sogar das geht um vierundneunzig Prozent zurück. Will man haben.
Ja
Moderner gibt's auch Neuigkeiten und zwar Moderne hat jetzt angefangen auch eine Phase zwei und drei Studie zu starten mit Kindern.
Das heißt, hier werden jetzt Kinder im Alter von einem halben bis sechs Jahre getestet,
Das läuft jetzt in USA an.
Keine Ahnung, wie lange das dann laufen wird, aber ist auf jeden Fall gut zu wissen, dass sowas überhaupt gestartet wird. Ich äh gehe also davon aus, dass wir dann so in den nächsten,
Monaten irgendwann auch mal ähm Informationen dafür bekommen werden, wie anwendbar die Impfstoffe auch für Kinder sind. Das ist nämlich so ein bisschen das, was noch äh fehlt.
Wobei man wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen kann äh dass äh die Tests positiv verlaufen äh werden. Aber man muss es trotzdem natürlich testen.
Ja, ich gehe davon auch aus, aber es wissen wir halt nicht.
Naja, nee, aber es ist sagen eigentlich auch, ich weiß gar nicht, ob's auch im Jahr, doch, ich glaube, es gibt Impfstoffe, die nicht bei Kindern zugelassen sind, aber eigentlich die meisten äh sagen.
Ja machen bei Kindern auch keine Probleme, aber ja, wir werden sehen.
Genau, werden wir sehen. Woran moderner auch arbeitet, was sie angekündigt haben, ist, dass sie an einer neuen Variante ihres Impfstoffs arbeiten. Und zwar,
mit zwei Zielrichtungen, erstens wollen sie für die Version zwei null ihres Impfstoffs ähm noch eine bessere Lagerfähigkeit haben, das heißt diese Lipidhülle
NA umschließt, wo meinen sie nochmal äh
optimieren zu können dahingehend, dass sie eben noch niedrigere Lagertemperaturen hinbekommen, dass sie also nicht so stark kühlen müssen.
Und äh die MRNA Information in dem Impfstoff wird dann auch angepasst sein für die B eins drei drei fünf, die Südafrikavariante. Weil da haben wir ja,
Wissen wir ja, das ist so einer von denen, die so ein bisschen Immunestape äh machen, die wollen halt äh ne.
Diese Variante mitmachen und ähm kann halt gut sein, dass mittelfristig dieser Impfstoff dann entweder den Alten ersetzt oder als dritte Booster-Impfung dann noch gesetzt wird. Was sich für wahrscheinliche halte.
Morgen. Gut.
Genau. Ja, zu guter Letzt gibt's dann noch eine Autosie Studie der Charité äh in Berlin.
Da haben sie sich wohl mal angeschaut, woran Leute die Hovit neunzehn erkrankt waren und die gestorben sind.
Denn eigentlich wirklich gestorben sind und das ist ja so diese.
Debatte, ne, die einem ja auch gerne äh von außen so aufgedrückt wird, so nach dem Motto, ja, die Leute waren zwar infiziert, aber wissen wir auch, dass sie daran gestorben sind und nicht an irgendwas anderem gestorben sind.
Und das wurde halt jetzt hier in so einer Studie äh gemacht, die kamen irgendwie auch schon im Februar raus, habe ich aber jetzt erst entdeckt und da wurde äh untersucht.
Wie denn das jetzt eigentlich gelaufen ist und ähm ohne jetzt die Zahlen runterbieten zu können, der die Kernaussage dieser Studie ist
Man kann davon ausgehen, dass die allermeisten Leute
schlicht und ergreifend an den unmittelbaren Folgen von neunzehn gestorben sind. Das also sozusagen die davon ausgelösten Symptome. Letztlich das waren was den Körper nieder gerungen hat und nicht irgendwelche anderen Sachen.
Ja. Und ich würde sagen zusammen auch mit.
Den äh einfach Berechnungen, die ich zufällig letzte Woche gemacht äh habe äh passt das äh einfach wunderbar, auch wenn man das mit dem Sterbe äh äh Statistiken äh zusammen
legt und richtig rechnet, weil ja war ja oft das Argument, was man auch hörte, ja gut
irgendwie jeden Tag sterben ja zwei bis dreitausend Leute sowieso und wenn da jetzt zehn oder zwanzig oder hundert dabei sind.
Die irgendwie Corona positiv getestet äh äh worden sind. Das bietet das ja.
Ja in so sagen bei der Gesamtzahl gar nicht wirklich die Rolle, so genau äh können wir gar nicht wissen, also wo die Leute dann verlangen, dass irgendwie statt zweitausend Leute jeden Tag irgendwie viertausend Leute sterben, dann erst ist Kovit
äh sozusagen ähm wirklich gefährlich, ganz abgesehen davon, dass wir.
Dass wir auch äh bereits äh solche Sterberaten erreicht haben, dass sich das auf die Sterbestatistik ausgewirkt hat.
Kam ich denn bei meinen Berechnungen darauf, dass irgendwo in der Größenordnung von zwei bis drei Prozent.
Der Leute, die positiv getestet wurden und dann innerhalb von dreißig Tagen nach einem positiven Test verstorben sind.
Dass du ja um die drei Prozent äh der positiv getesteten äh auch ohne die positiven Tests gestorben werden. Sage ich mal.
Aber das ist sozusagen die Größenordnung und des deswegen und selbst, ich habe das dann nochmal für die Altersgruppe achtzig plus gemacht, da sind's ein bisschen mehr, da sind's dann vier Prozent. Äh ja, aber selbst,
von den über achtzigjährigen so hätten sechsundneunzig Prozent.
Wären dann nicht gestorben, beziehungsweise äh zwei Drittel von denen hätten fünf Jahre später auch noch gelebt. Das heißt ähm ja,
ich zitiere dann immer gerne meine Zahl von, dass wir ungefähr hundertfünfzigtausend Lebensjahre von über achtzigjährigen verloren äh haben in der letzten Welle. So.
Und eigentlich ja ist.
Sozusagen mit dieser Studie und auch äh mit den Statistiken ist die Frage so sterben die Menschen an oder mit Kowit äh einfach ähm.
Beantwortet, endgültig beantwortet so äh and of Discussion, braucht man nicht mehr drüber zu reden ähm so der Fall ist klar.
Ganz einfach.
Ganz einfach. Gut dann wollen wir äh natürlich jetzt dafür sorgen, dass ihr jetzt nicht noch mehr Lebenszeit mit dem Hören dieses Podcasts äh.
Ja das multipliziert sich mittlerweile auch äh ganz gut, ja? Wir hatten jetzt in der letzten Woche äh doch,
ein spürbar gesteigerten Zuspruch, so wie ich das in den Downloadzahlen festmachen können, haben wir irgendwie binnen einer Woche jetzt das erste Mal die dreißigtausend Downloads äh ähm
beobachten können, das finde ich ziemlich bemerkenswert und da bedanke ich mich vor bei allen, die offenbar unseren Podcast so ein bisschen weitergereicht und weiterempfohlen haben.
Richtig baff erstaunt war ich, als ich den sogar auf der äh Ressourcen zu Coffee neunzehn im Internetliste der Universität Greifswald gefunden habe
wurde auch dein äh deine Zahlendreherei äh nochmal explizit hervorgehoben, Pavel.
Ja hört man gerne, also gegen ja sagen, wer ist schon immun gegen Lob und Schmeichelei? Äh so das nehme ich jederzeit äh.
Nutze gerne entgegen. Vielleicht gibt's ja auch einen Impfstoff dagegen. Aber willst du gar nicht, ne? Ist der einzige, den du nicht möchtest? Nee, muss ja ordentlich sein. Ja
Ich bedanke mich einfach mal äh nochmal bei allen, die uns hier unterstützen, die die Mitterebene auch finanziell unterstützen und allen, die äh im Clubhaus schon viel interessantes Feed.
Gegeben haben. Die Runde am Dienstag machen wir auf jeden Fall auch weiter. Ja und dann war's das glaube ich erstmal für diese Woche oder Paveln.
Ja, wir hätten zwar, könnten zwar noch eine Stunde äh weiter äh machen, aber ich glaube ähm.
Ist schon nachts um ein.
Ja, es ist schön, ist schön äh rund geworden und ist nicht so, das ist, was ich nicht auch noch äh Dinge zu tun hätte.
Genau und derzeit fliegen die Informationen nur so rein, also werden wir nächste Woche wieder was für euch haben. Insofern sagen wir jetzt tschüss und.